Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. At around 6 a.m. 1 1994, 16-year-old Aaron Bacon lay sleeping in his bed in the home where he lived with his parents in Phoenix, Arizona. The quiet of the early morning hour was broken by a high-pitched noise outside Aaron's closed bedroom door. One of the family's three pet
我们的剧集涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您在应用程序或我们网站上本剧集的节目说明。1994年3月1日凌晨6点左右，16岁的亚伦·培根（Aaron Bacon）躺在亚利桑那州凤凰城他与父母同住的家中床上睡觉。清晨的宁静被亚伦紧闭的卧室门外传来的尖锐噪音打破。家里三只宠物狗中的一只
Sharpeys was whining. The sound woke Aaron, and soon he heard their other two dogs start to growl and bark as well. Aaron's bedroom door suddenly swung open and three men walked in. Two of them were strangers who Aaron had never seen before. The third was his father. As Aaron lay confused and stunned in bed, his father said, Sally and Bob Bacon had been worried about their youngest son for some time. Aaron had always been a bright, talented and exceptionally empathetic child. When he was little, his mother had discovered that he was making peanut butter sandwiches and leaving them out for unhoused people who lived in the same historic district of Phoenix that they called home. He stood up for kids at school who were being bullied, and he was passionate about music
沙皮犬在呜咽。声音吵醒了亚伦，很快他也听到另外两只狗开始咆哮和吠叫。亚伦的卧室门突然被推开，三个男人走了进来。其中两个是亚伦从未见过的陌生人。第三个是他的父亲。当亚伦困惑而震惊地躺在床上时，他的父亲说，萨莉（Sally）和鲍勃·培根（Bob Bacon）夫妇已经为他们的小儿子担心了一段时间。亚伦一直是个聪明、有天赋且极其善解人意的孩子。小时候，母亲发现他会做花生酱三明治，留给住在他们凤凰城老城区家附近的无家可归者。他在学校里为被欺负的孩子挺身而出，并且热爱音乐
and writing poetry. But things had slowly started to change when Aaron was in the eighth grade. The problems began when his brother Jared, three years older than Aaron and the only other child of Sally and Bob Bacon, began experimenting with recreational drugs. Aaron was unhappy about this. His father Bob was a recovering alcoholic. By 1994, he had been sober for eight and a half years and was doing well with a thriving career as an architect and a designer. Bob had always been very upfront with his sons about this, teaching them about the dangers of addiction. Yet when Jared started using drugs, neither Bob nor Sally confronted him about
和写诗。但当亚伦上八年级时，情况开始慢慢发生变化。问题始于他的哥哥贾里德（Jared），他比亚伦大三岁，是萨莉和鲍勃·培根夫妇的另一个孩子，开始尝试娱乐性药物。亚伦对此很不高兴。他的父亲鲍勃曾是一名酗酒者，正在康复中。到1994年，他已经戒酒八年半，事业蒸蒸日上，是一名成功的建筑师和设计师。鲍勃一直对儿子们非常坦诚，教导他们成瘾的危害。然而，当贾里德开始吸毒时，鲍勃和萨莉都没有找他谈过
it, which upset Aaron. Jared eventually asked his mother for help and his parents sent them to a respected rehab facility in Minnesota. The experience didn't seem to change Jared's behaviour and he continued to smoke cannabis after leaving the facility. He eventually stopped using drugs on his own a few years later. But six months after Jared had entered rehab, Aaron began to experiment for himself. He started smoking cannabis and taking psychedelics. Aaron had always been a top student, but his grades began to drop. He campaigned to be allowed to change schools, leaving the exclusive private school he attended for a public one called Central High. Aaron told his parents he felt stifled by his current school
这件事，这让亚伦感到不安。贾里德最终向母亲寻求帮助，父母将他送往明尼苏达州一家受人尊敬的康复中心。这段经历似乎并没有改变贾里德的行为，他在离开中心后继续吸食大麻。几年后，他最终自己停止了吸毒。但在贾里德进入康复中心六个月后，亚伦开始自己尝试。他开始吸食大麻并服用迷幻药。亚伦一直是一名优等生，但他的成绩开始下滑。他争取转学，离开了他就读的贵族私立学校，转入了一所名为中央高中（Central High）的公立学校。亚伦告诉父母，他觉得现在的学校让他感到压抑
and wanted to study somewhere with a more diverse student body. His girlfriend also attended Central High, adding to its appeal. Sally and Bob had agreed, but were disappointed when the switch didn't seem to make Aaron any happier or more settled. In fact, his behaviour grew worse. He would take the family car out at night without permission, getting into minor scrapes and later denying it when his parents noticed the damage. Aaron was increasingly withdrawn and irritable, no longer confiding in his mother as he once had. The final straw came in February of 1994 when Aaron was attacked by members of a street gang in his school parking lot. Witnesses to the
并想去一个学生群体更多元化的地方学习。他的女朋友也在中央高中上学，这增加了学校的吸引力。萨莉和鲍勃同意了，但令他们失望的是，转学似乎并没有让亚伦变得更快乐或更稳定。事实上，他的行为变得更糟了。他会在晚上未经许可开走家里的车，造成轻微擦伤，后来在父母发现损坏时又予以否认。亚伦变得越来越孤僻和易怒，不再像以前那样向母亲吐露心声。最后一根稻草出现在1994年2月，当时亚伦在学校停车场被一个街头帮派的成员袭击。袭击的目击者
assault said that it didn't appear to be a random incident. It looked like the gang members knew Aaron. They had called him Rabbit, a nickname that suggested familiarity. Sally and Bob wondered if Aaron was in fact an associate of the gang. He was now smoking pot regularly. What if the attack had been drug related? Concerned that their youngest son might have escalated from taking drugs to selling them, Sally and Bob knew they had to do something as soon as possible. They pulled Aaron out of school and considered their options. They were already in family therapy, which they'd started after Aaron started stealing their car. Sally and Bob did not want to send Aaron to a rehab facility as they had with their older
说，这看起来不像是一起随机事件。看起来帮派成员认识亚伦。他们叫他“兔子”（Rabbit），这个绰号暗示了他们很熟悉。萨莉和鲍勃怀疑亚伦实际上是否是该帮派的成员。他现在经常吸食大麻。如果袭击与毒品有关怎么办？萨莉和鲍勃担心他们的小儿子可能从吸毒升级为贩毒，他们知道必须尽快采取行动。他们让亚伦退学并考虑了各种选择。他们已经在进行家庭治疗，这是在亚伦开始偷他们的车之后开始的。萨莉和鲍勃不想像对待大儿子那样把亚伦送到康复中心。
son. Sally had realised that the reason the facility hadn't helped Jared was likely because he didn't have an actual addiction. The same was true for Aaron, he just needed some guidance to set him on a better course. Then Sally remembered something she'd heard about from a friend. Her friend had told her about a wilderness therapy camp designed especially for troubled teens, located in the southern region of Utah. Sally's friend knew a couple who had sent their rebellious son there, and he'd reportedly emerged with a wonderful new attitude.
萨莉意识到，康复中心之所以没能帮助贾里德，很可能是因为他并没有真正的毒瘾。亚伦也是如此，他只是需要一些指导来走上正轨。这时，萨莉想起从朋友那里听说过的一件事。她的朋友告诉她一个专门为问题少年设计的荒野治疗营，位于犹他州南部地区。萨莉的朋友认识一对夫妇，他们把叛逆的儿子送到了那里，据报道他回来时态度有了极好的转变。
The program was called North Star Expeditions. The program was called North Star Expeditions. North Star had been founded four years earlier by a former military policeman named Lance Jagger. It was one of many such camps that had sprung up in Utah and other western United States during the 1980s and 90s. In fact, it was estimated that there were roughly 115 organizations that offered wilderness programs designed to assist so-called troubled youths across the entire country. Away from televisions, computer games, and friends deemed to be a bad influence, teenagers who attended these programs could reconnect with the natural world via long, difficult hikes and sleeping outside. They were taught outdoor survival skills,
这个项目叫“北极星探险”（North Star Expeditions）。这个项目叫“北极星探险”。北极星是四年前由一位名叫兰斯·贾格尔（Lance Jagger）的前军事警察创立的。它是20世纪80年代和90年代在犹他州及美国西部涌现出的众多此类营地之一。事实上，据估计，全国大约有115个组织提供旨在帮助所谓“问题青少年”的荒野项目。远离电视、电脑游戏和被认为有不良影响的朋友，参加这些项目的青少年可以通过漫长、艰苦的徒步旅行和露营与自然世界重新建立联系。他们被教授户外生存技能，
such as starting a fire with no matches as a way to improve their discipline and self-esteem. Sally and Bob Bacon were intrigued by the idea of wilderness therapy. They called North Star Expeditions and asked for a brochure. North Star's base camp was located in the small Utah town of Escalante which in 1994 was home to less than a thousand people. Situated in the south central part of the state on the scenic Utah Byway, it was also home to stunning natural scenery. Red rock canyons and sprawling deserts surrounded the town. There were four phases to North Star's 63 day program.
比如不用火柴生火，以此来提高他们的纪律性和自尊心。萨莉和鲍勃·培根对荒野治疗的想法很感兴趣。他们打电话给“北极星探险”索要宣传册。北极星的基地营位于犹他州埃斯卡兰特（Escalante）小镇，1994年那里的人口不到一千人。它位于该州中南部，坐落在风景优美的犹他州公路上，也拥有令人惊叹的自然风光。红岩峡谷和广阔的沙漠环绕着小镇。北极星的63天项目分为四个阶段。
A-Team was the first phase, an orientation portion for new arrivals. Then they graduated to Primitive, where they were transported out to the Escalante River Basin and provided with backpacks, sleeping bags, and clothing. This phase began with a 48-hour fast, after which attendees were given a week's worth of food supplies. They had to cook their food themselves and it mostly consisted of rice, lentils, oatmeal, as well as some vegetables and proteins. Next came the handcarts phase where teens would learn to work together as a team. The final phase was llamas, which taught care for animals and prepared the youths for their return home.
“A队”（A-Team）是第一阶段，是为新来者准备的适应期。然后他们进入“原始阶段”（Primitive），在那里他们被运送到埃斯卡兰特河流域，并配有背包、睡袋和衣服。这一阶段以48小时禁食开始，之后参与者会获得一周的食物供应。他们必须自己做饭，食物主要包括米饭、扁豆、燕麦片，以及一些蔬菜和蛋白质。接下来是“手推车阶段”（handcarts），青少年们将学习如何作为一个团队共同工作。最后阶段是“美洲驼阶段”（llamas），教授照顾动物的知识，并为青少年回家做准备。
After reading about the company and its many success stories, the Bakens spoke with North Star representatives over the phone. They were told that the campers hiked for around 8 to 10 hours a day, then sat by a campfire at night, writing in their journals and chatting about their issues with trained experts. Sally Bacon thought this sounded perfect for Aaron. He was a thoughtful, introspective boy who was content being alone and loved to write. Sally could picture him sitting by a fire, scribbling away and having plenty of time for reflection while surrounded by stunning scenery. It almost sounded like it would be a vacation for him. The Bakens were given a list of names of parents whom they could call to ask about their own
在阅读了关于该公司及其许多成功案例的信息后，培根夫妇通过电话与北极星的代表进行了交谈。他们被告知，营员们每天徒步约8到10小时，晚上坐在篝火旁，在日记中写作，并与训练有素的专家聊天讨论他们的问题。萨莉·培根认为这听起来对亚伦来说很完美。他是一个善于思考、内省的男孩，满足于独处，并且热爱写作。萨莉可以想象他坐在火堆旁，奋笔疾书，在被迷人风景环绕的同时有充足的时间进行反思。这听起来几乎就像是他的度假。培根夫妇得到了一份家长的名单，他们可以打电话询问这些家长关于他们自己的
children's experiences at the camp. Sally also ran the idea by their family therapist. Every person Sally spoke with was in favour of Aaron attending North Star. Convinced that North Star sounded like the right fit for Aaron, Sally and Bob decided to proceed. It wasn't going to be cheap. The program cost $13,900 and also charged for interstate transportation as Aaron would be travelling over from Arizona. Northstar also said that for an extra $775, one of the organisation's owners, Lance Jagger, would fly to Phoenix and personally escort Aaron to the camp. They recommended this approach over parents bringing their child to Northstar, as it would set the new tone for the troubled teen from the get-go and prevent unpleasant family fights. Sally and Bob agreed and took out a second mortgage on their home to
孩子在营地的经历。萨莉还向他们的家庭治疗师咨询了这个想法。萨莉交谈过的每个人都赞成亚伦参加北极星。萨莉和鲍勃确信北极星非常适合亚伦，于是决定继续进行。这并不便宜。该项目费用为13,900美元，还收取州际交通费，因为亚伦将从亚利桑那州赶来。北极星还表示，只要额外支付775美元，该组织的所有者之一兰斯·贾格尔就会飞往凤凰城，亲自护送亚伦前往营地。他们建议采用这种方式，而不是由父母带孩子去北极星，因为这能从一开始就为问题少年定下基调，并防止不愉快的家庭争吵。萨莉和鲍勃同意了，并为他们的房子办理了二次抵押贷款以
fund the costs. The day before Aaron was due to be taken to Utah, the couple met with Lance Jagger and his wife Barbara at a hotel in Phoenix. The four had a long meeting to discuss the finer details of the plan. Sally also wanted to voice some final concerns. Arryn was tall at just under six feet and thin, weighing 131 pounds or roughly 59 kilograms. Sally was worried that the program, which saw teenagers receive fairly basic food, might lead to him shedding weight he couldn't afford to lose. Barbara reassured Sally that they would never let any of their campers lose weight. Sally wanted to know what the protocol was when a
支付费用。在亚伦被带往犹他州的前一天，这对夫妇在凤凰城的一家酒店会见了兰斯·贾格尔和他的妻子芭芭拉（Barbara）。四人进行了长时间的会谈，讨论了计划的细节。萨莉还想表达最后的一些担忧。亚伦身高不到六英尺，身材瘦削，体重131磅，大约59公斤。萨莉担心这个项目让青少年吃相当基本的食物，可能会导致他减掉他无法承受的体重。芭芭拉向萨莉保证，他们绝不会让任何营员体重减轻。萨莉想知道当一个
teenager made a complaint. What if, for example, a camper reported that they had been sexually abused by one of the camp leaders? How would North Star handle that? Lance and Barbara explained that if a child made a complaint, someone from the North Star office would be immediately dispatched to the location where the teens were camping to investigate the matter. But the Bakens wouldn't need to worry because Aaron would be well cared for. His days would be spent in some of the most beautiful locations in the western United States and there would be therapists on hand for him to talk through his issues with. Bob warned that Aaron wasn't the type of person who responded well to threats or intimidation tactics. A hostile approach wouldn't work on him. Lance told Bob not to worry, stating,
青少年提出投诉时，协议是什么。例如，如果一名营员报告说他们受到了营地领导之一的性虐待，北极星会如何处理？兰斯和芭芭拉解释说，如果孩子提出投诉，北极星办公室的人会立即被派往青少年露营的地点调查此事。但培根夫妇不必担心，因为亚伦会得到很好的照顾。他将在美国西部一些最美丽的地方度过时光，并且会有治疗师在场供他倾诉问题。鲍勃警告说，亚伦不是那种对威胁或恐吓手段反应良好的人。敌对的方法对他不起作用。兰斯告诉鲍勃不要担心，并说：
I have a special gift for working with kids. They really open up to me. really open up to me." Early the next morning, Lance Jagger and a colleague arrived at the Bacon residence to collect Aaron. Sally and Bob had mentioned Northstar as a possibility to Aaron, but the unannounced and somewhat aggressive collection process totally shocked him. As Aaron still lay in bed, his father explained that the other two men in his room were there to help, and he wanted Aaron to go with them. Aaron started to get up when one of the two men reached out and roughly grabbed his arm. He was large and weighed almost
“我在与孩子打交道方面有特殊的天赋。他们真的会向我敞开心扉。”第二天一早，兰斯·贾格尔和一名同事来到培根家接亚伦。萨莉和鲍勃曾向亚伦提到过北极星的可能性，但这种未经通知且带有某种侵略性的接人过程让他彻底震惊了。当亚伦还躺在床上时，他的父亲解释说房间里的另外两个男人是来帮忙的，他希望亚伦跟他们走。亚伦刚要起身，其中一个男人就伸出手粗暴地抓住了他的手臂。他身材魁梧，体重几乎是
twice as much as the scrawny 16-year-old. Aaron tried to slip out of his grasp, prompting the man to take hold of Aaron's shoulders and push him back down on the bed. You're coming with me, he said. If I detect any resistance, I'll assume you are trying to get away and I'll take the appropriate action. Do I make myself clear?" When Aaron was escorted from his bedroom flanked by Lance and his co-worker, Sally could see how scared he looked. She moved to hug him goodbye, but Lance didn't allow Aaron to hug his mother back. Sally kissed Aaron on the cheek and said, I love you. Aaron was silent. After he left the home, driven away to the airport by his handlers, Bob began to cry. Sally and Bob weren't allowed to talk to Aaron while he was at Northstar.
这个瘦弱的16岁少年的两倍。亚伦试图从他的掌握中挣脱，促使那个人抓住亚伦的肩膀把他按回床上。“你跟我走，”他说。“如果我发现任何反抗，我会认为你在试图逃跑，我会采取适当的行动。我说明白了吗？”当亚伦在兰斯和他的同事护送下走出卧室时，萨莉能看出他有多害怕。她走过去拥抱他告别，但兰斯不允许亚伦拥抱母亲。萨莉亲吻了亚伦的脸颊说：“我爱你。”亚伦沉默不语。在他离开家，被看守人开车送往机场后，鲍勃开始哭泣。萨莉和鲍勃在亚伦在北极星期间不允许与他通话。
They were permitted to call the head office once a week for a report on Aaron's progress. Sally typically called and would speak to either Barbara Jagger or another staff member named Daryl Bartholomew. They always told her things were fine, though Aaron was rebelling somewhat. Barbara said he'd tried to manipulate her, while Dryl described him as belligerent and a whiner who was refusing to carry his pack on hikes. The other kids in the program didn't like him. These descriptions didn't sound like Aaron as far as Sally was concerned, but she rationalised that by telling herself the program coordinators were likely jaded from their experience working with teenagers who really were manipulative.
他们被允许每周给总部打一次电话，询问亚伦的进展报告。萨莉通常会打电话，与芭芭拉·贾格尔或另一位名叫达里尔·巴塞洛缪（Daryl Bartholomew）的工作人员交谈。他们总是告诉她一切都好，尽管亚伦有些反叛。芭芭拉说他试图操纵她，而达里尔则形容他是一个好战且爱抱怨的人，拒绝在徒步时背负背包。项目里的其他孩子不喜欢他。在萨莉看来，这些描述听起来不像亚伦，但她通过告诉自己项目协调员可能因为与真正具有操纵性的青少年打交道而变得麻木来合理化这一点。
Several weeks passed. One day, Sally received a call from Northstar asking her a question. Was it true she had a rare form of epilepsy that could sometimes cause loss of bowel control? Sally affirmed that this was true and asked why they wanted to know. The staff member told her that Aaron had soiled himself and told his camp counsellors about his mother's condition. He said he was worried that he might have inherited it. This alarmed Sally. She told the staff member that had never happened before and Aaron had shown no signs of having epilepsy. She couldn't understand why he would soil himself, which was something that hadn't happened since he was an infant. The staff member reassured
几周过去了。一天，萨莉接到北极星的电话，问了她一个问题。她是否患有一种罕见的癫痫症，有时会导致肠道失控？萨莉肯定了这一点，并询问他们为什么要问。工作人员告诉她，亚伦弄脏了裤子，并告诉了他的营地辅导员关于他母亲的情况。他说他担心自己可能遗传了这种病。这让萨莉感到震惊。她告诉工作人员，这种情况以前从未发生过，亚伦也没有表现出患有癫痫的迹象。她无法理解他为什么会弄脏裤子，这是他婴儿时期以后就没发生过的事。工作人员向
her that nothing was really wrong with Aaron. Teenagers in the program pulled stunts like that all the time. Sometimes if they were hiking and not permitted to stop to go to the bathroom, they would soil themselves to make a statement. Sally was confused. She asked why they wouldn't just be allowed to use the bathroom in the first place, but was merely told it wasn't always possible if they were trekking up a hill. On the evening of Wednesday March 30, Sally called Northstar for another progress update. Sally called Northstar for another progress update. Aaron was nearing the end of one month at the camp. Unfortunately, the news wasn't positive. Darryl Bartholomew told Sally that Aaron wasn't cooperating with them and was trying to obtain
她保证亚伦并没有什么大碍。项目里的青少年经常搞这种把戏。有时如果他们在徒步旅行，不允许停下来上厕所，他们会弄脏裤子来表达不满。萨莉很困惑。她问为什么不直接允许他们上厕所，但只是被告知如果他们在爬山，这并不总是可能的。3月30日星期三晚上，萨莉打电话给北极星询问另一个进展更新。萨莉打电话给北极星询问另一个进展更新。亚伦在营地的时间即将满一个月。不幸的是，消息并不乐观。达里尔·巴塞洛缪告诉萨莉，亚伦不配合他们，并试图获取
other kids food despite having his own to eat. His attitude was so poor that he'd have to repeat the program. Distraught by this news, Sally went to bed crying that night. As she lay there, she prayed that things would improve for Aaron. The following day, Sally was driving when she received a notification on her pager to call North Star. When she arrived home, she phoned the organisation's head office and spoke to Barbara Jagger. "'Aaron is down.
其他孩子的食物，尽管他自己有吃的。他的态度太差了，以至于他必须重修这个项目。萨莉被这个消息弄得心烦意乱，那天晚上哭着上床睡觉。当她躺在那里时，她祈祷亚伦的情况能有所好转。第二天，萨莉正在开车时，寻呼机收到通知，让她给北极星打电话。当她回到家时，她给该组织的总部打了电话，并与芭芭拉·贾格尔交谈。“亚伦倒下了。
We can't get a pulse,' Barbara told her." Sally didn't understand what Barbara was saying. When she asked what that meant, Barbara explained that Aaron had been airlifted to a hospital in Page, Arizona. Sally should call her husband, Bob, as he'd already been notified and had the hospital's number. Sally immediately called her husband at work. He sounded numb and spoke directly, telling Sally that apparently there had been some sort of freak accident at the camp. Aaron had collapsed, possibly after eating something poisonous. Camp leaders had done all they could to revive him, but nothing had worked. Aaron was dead.
我们测不到脉搏了，”芭芭拉告诉她。萨莉不明白芭芭拉在说什么。当她问这意味着什么时，芭芭拉解释说亚伦已被空运到亚利桑那州佩奇市（Page）的一家医院。萨莉应该给她的丈夫鲍勃打电话，因为他已经接到通知，并有医院的电话号码。萨莉立即给在工作的丈夫打了电话。他听起来麻木且说话直接，告诉萨莉，营地里似乎发生了一场某种离奇的事故。亚伦晕倒了，可能是在吃了什么有毒的东西之后。营地领导尽了他们所能来抢救他，但没有任何效果。亚伦死了。
Three days later, Aaron's remains arrived at a mortuary in Phoenix. The devastated and shocked Sally and Bob went there to identify him. As the sheet was removed from Aaron's body, Sally covered her eyes and began to scream. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. This episode of Casefile is sponsored by BetterHelp. Kids are constantly learning and growing, but as adults we sometimes lose that sense of curiosity. What's something you'd like to learn?
三天后，亚伦的遗体抵达凤凰城的一家殡仪馆。悲痛欲绝且震惊的萨莉和鲍勃去那里认领他。当床单从亚伦的身体上移开时，萨莉捂住眼睛开始尖叫。Casefile稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本剧集的赞助商来支持我们。本期Casefile由BetterHelp赞助。孩子们在不断学习和成长，但作为成年人，我们有时会失去那种好奇心。有什么你想学习的东西吗？
Maybe a new language, playing an instrument, or learning to cook? Therapy can help you reconnect with your sense of wonder, proving that your back to school phase can happen at any age. The team at Casefile are firm believers in the benefits of therapy. It's not just for those who have experienced major trauma. Therapy can teach you coping skills, help you set boundaries, and give you the space to explore your thoughts and feelings without judgement. If you've been thinking about starting therapy, consider giving BetterHelp a try. It's an online platform designed to be convenient, flexible, and tailored to your schedule. You
也许是一门新语言、演奏一种乐器，或者学习烹饪？治疗可以帮助你重新找回你的惊奇感，证明你的“返校”阶段可以在任何年龄发生。Casefile团队坚信治疗的好处。它不仅仅适用于那些经历过重大创伤的人。治疗可以教你应对技巧，帮助你设定界限，并给你空间去探索你的想法和感受，而不受评判。如果你一直在考虑开始治疗，请考虑尝试一下BetterHelp。这是一个在线平台，旨在方便、灵活，并根据你的日程安排进行定制。你
simply fill out a brief questionnaire and BetterHelp will match you with a licensed therapist. Plus, if you feel the need to switch therapists, you can do so at any time with no extra cost. Rediscover your curiosity with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash case file today to get 10% off your first month. file today to get 10% off your first month. That's better help. H-E-L-P dot com slash case file. Some say financial crime is victimless, but that definitely isn't the case, especially when it ends in murder. You need to check out Money Crimes, a new show hosted by bestselling author and entrepreneur Nicole Appen. Money Crimes is about the world's biggest financial scandals and how they can spiral
只需填写一份简短的问卷，BetterHelp就会为你匹配一位持证治疗师。此外，如果你觉得需要更换治疗师，你可以随时更换，无需额外费用。通过BetterHelp重新发现你的好奇心。今天访问betterhelp.com/casefile，首次购买可享受10%的折扣。这就是betterhelp.com/casefile。有些人说金融犯罪是无受害者的，但这绝对不是事实，尤其是当它以谋杀告终时。你需要看看《金钱犯罪》（Money Crimes），这是一档由畅销书作家兼企业家妮可·阿彭（Nicole Appen）主持的新节目。《金钱犯罪》讲述了世界上最重大的金融丑闻，以及它们如何以你意想不到的方式失控。
out of control in ways you'd never expect. From cunning Ponzi schemes to cutthroat politics and even murderous con artists, you'll learn that the finance world is more dangerous than you ever imagined, and most importantly, how to protect yourself from it. Money Crimes is a Crime House original powered by PAVE Studios. New episodes release every Thursday. Just search for Money for money crimes. That's M-O-N-E-Y-C-R-I-M-E-S. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. When Aaron Bacon first arrived at North Star's base camp, he was strip searched and given a medical exam. Blood and urine tests revealed he had traces of cannabis in his system, but there was
从狡猾的庞氏骗局到残酷的政治，甚至是谋杀性的骗子，你将了解到金融世界比你想象的更危险，最重要的是，如何保护自己免受其害。Money Crimes是Crime House的原创节目，由PAVE Studios提供支持。新剧集于每周四发布。只需搜索Money Crimes。这就是M-O-N-E-Y-C-R-I-M-E-S。感谢您收听本剧集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。当亚伦·培根第一次到达北极星的基地营时，他被脱光衣服搜身并接受了体检。血液和尿液测试显示他的系统中有大麻痕迹，但没有
nothing else of concern. Staff members shaved offon's long hair and provided him with clothing, including a hooded sweatshirt, three shirts, three pairs of cotton pants, socks, underwear, and a pair of cheap hiking boots that were two sizes too small. He was also given a journal. All North Star participants had to write in their journals daily as well as compose an essay outlining what they had done to be sent there. Everything the teenagers wrote was read by Northstar's staff members, including letters home to loved ones. In Aaron's essay, he expressed his belief that his parents were making a mistake by sending him to Northstar. Quote, If I am forced to change, this program seems ready to force me. This is not my
其他令人担忧的问题。工作人员剃掉了亚伦的长发，并为他提供了衣服，包括一件连帽衫、三件衬衫、三条棉裤、袜子、内衣，以及一双小了两码的廉价徒步靴。他还得到了一本日记。所有北极星的参与者都必须每天在日记中写作，并写一篇概述他们为什么被送到这里的文章。青少年写的一切都被北极星的工作人员阅读，包括写给亲人的家书。在亚伦的文章中，他表达了自己的信念，即他的父母把他送到北极星是一个错误。引用：“如果我被迫改变，这个项目似乎准备强迫我。这不是我
parents' last resort. Child abuse, which I think this program is, is never a resort. It only results in the opposite. Aaron clashed with Northstar's owner, Lance Jagger, whose rough, hewn style was the opposite of Aaron's more intellectual personality. Nevertheless, Aaron soon tried to adopt a more positive approach. He apologised to Lance's wife Barbara for being rude when they first met, explaining that he didn't usually behave that way but he'd been angry about the situation he found himself in. His apology was rejected by Barbara, who replied, You're so full of shit. Aaron, you're trying to manipulate me.
父母的最后手段。虐待儿童，我认为这个项目就是这样，永远不是一种手段。它只会导致相反的结果。”亚伦与北极星的所有者兰斯·贾格尔发生了冲突，兰斯粗犷的风格与亚伦更理性的个性截然相反。尽管如此，亚伦很快尝试采取更积极的态度。他为第一次见面时的粗鲁向兰斯的妻子芭芭拉道歉，解释说他通常不会那样表现，但他对自己所处的境地感到愤怒。他的道歉被芭芭拉拒绝了，她回答说：“你满嘴胡言，亚伦，你是在试图操纵我。”
Aaron and five other new arrivals soon started the first phase of the program. A-Team. Designed to help the teenagers acclimatize to both their physical surroundings and the program's style, A- team involved camping in the wilderness for 10 days. They were driven out to the desert to stay in rough terrain at 5600 feet elevation. In March, the temperature during the day was chilly and it dropped to below freezing at night.
亚伦和其他五名新来者很快开始了该项目的第一阶段：A队。A队旨在帮助青少年适应他们的物理环境和项目的风格，包括在荒野中露营10天。他们被开车送到沙漠，停留在海拔5600英尺的崎岖地形上。三月份，白天的气温很冷，晚上则降至冰点以下。
All participants were given a backpack that they had to keep all their provisions in, including a sleeping bag. Aaron, who was used to the warmer weather in Phoenix, struggled with the freezing cold climate. The clothes he'd been given weren't warm enough, and he described shaking uncontrollably from his arrival on. A few days into a team, Aaron's stomach started to hurt badly and he had problems with his bowel movements. He was also hungry and craving a proper meal. Most of the rations he was given, such as oatmeal and lentils, had to be cooked over an open fire. The teams were each responsible for cooking their own meals and had to learn to light their own fires using a Native American technique in which
所有参与者都得到一个背包，他们必须把所有的补给品都放在里面，包括睡袋。习惯了凤凰城温暖天气的亚伦，在严寒的气候中挣扎。他得到的衣服不够暖和，他描述说从到达开始就无法控制地颤抖。A队开始几天后，亚伦的胃开始剧烈疼痛，排便也出现了问题。他也感到饥饿，渴望吃一顿正餐。他得到的大部分口粮，如燕麦片和扁豆，必须在露天火堆上烹饪。每个小组负责烹饪自己的饭菜，并必须学习使用一种美洲原住民的技术来生火，即将
a piece of wood was inserted into a socket drilled in another piece of wood and spun quickly. If a student failed to light their own fire, they weren't allowed to use another teenager's fire or sit by one to stay warm. Aaron struggled to learn the technique and was unable to start a fire. Consequently, he often went hungry. Despite not mastering firestarting, Aaron was moved into the second phase of the program called Primitive. This involved a gruelling six-week hike. Aaron's group of six teenagers was led by three camp counsellors employed by Northstar, 19-year-old Craig Fisher, 20-year-old Sonny Duncan, and 21-year-old Jeff Hauenstein. Only two councillors stayed with the group at any given time, with the
一根木头插入在另一块木头上钻出的插槽中并快速旋转。如果学生无法生火，他们就不允许使用其他青少年的火，也不允许坐在火堆旁取暖。亚伦努力学习这种技术，但无法生火。因此，他经常挨饿。尽管没有掌握生火技术，亚伦还是被调到了项目的第二阶段，称为“原始阶段”。这涉及为期六周的艰苦徒步旅行。亚伦的六人青少年小组由北极星雇佣的三名营地辅导员带领：19岁的克雷格·费舍尔（Craig Fisher）、20岁的桑尼·邓肯（Sonny Duncan）和21岁的杰夫·豪恩斯坦（Jeff Hauenstein）。任何时候只有两名辅导员与小组在一起，
three young men rotating shifts to take turns. Primitive began with the teens undertaking a 48-hour fast while simultaneously trekking through rough terrain. Aaron, who still had an intense stomach ache, wrote of how bad he felt. But he tried to put a positive spin on things, noting that the next couple of weeks would both test my physical limitations and broaden them. would both test my physical limitations and broaden them. The hiking was difficult. It involved lots of clambering across sharp rocks and steep cliffs. As Aaron's boots were too small for his backpack, he also started to trip and fall. After the first fall, Aaron struggled to regain his feet due to the weight of the pack. He
三名年轻人轮流值班。原始阶段以青少年进行48小时禁食开始，同时在崎岖的地形中跋涉。亚伦仍然胃痛剧烈，写下了他感觉有多糟糕。但他试图把事情往积极的方向想，指出接下来的几周既会考验我的身体极限，也会拓宽它们。徒步旅行很困难。它涉及在尖锐的岩石和陡峭的悬崖上攀爬。由于亚伦的靴子对他的背包来说太小了，他也开始绊倒。第一次摔倒后，由于背包的重量，亚伦挣扎着站起来。他
eventually managed, but soon fell again. His legs felt weak like jelly. After this second fall, his entire body was numb and he couldn't lift his arms. When Aaron reported these issues to his counsellors, they dismissed Aaron's complaints, believing he was feigning discomfort and pain to get out of the program. They told him to stop being lazy. The more Aaron complained about feeling sick and dizzy, the more harshly he was criticised. It wasn't long before some of the other teens and even the counsellors were calling him gay, using the word as a derogatory slur to imply Aaron was weak and not masculine enough. On Sunday March 13, two days into the hike, the group was permitted to break their fast. All of the teenagers were given a can of peaches. But during the hike that day,
最终成功了，但很快又摔倒了。他的腿感觉像果冻一样无力。第二次摔倒后，他的整个身体都麻木了，他无法抬起手臂。当亚伦向辅导员报告这些问题时，他们驳回了亚伦的投诉，认为他是在假装不适和疼痛以逃避项目。他们告诉他不要再懒惰了。亚伦越是抱怨感到恶心和头晕，就越受到严厉的批评。没过多久，一些其他青少年甚至辅导员就开始叫他“同性恋”（gay），用这个词作为贬义词来暗示亚伦软弱且不够阳刚。3月13日星期日，徒步旅行的第二天，小组被允许结束禁食。所有的青少年都得到了一罐桃子。但在那天徒步旅行时，
Aaron continued to trip and fall. At one stage, when he tried to climb through a canyon, he slipped and hit his chin on a rock, cutting it open. Aaron wrote in his journal, I'm just so enveloped in pain. The staff didn't seem to care one bit. After this, Aaron started suffering nosebleeds. He continued to feel the cold intensely. Two days after his bad fall, Aaron said he could no longer carry his pack. The weight was just too heavy and he wasn't strong enough to hike with it anymore. The counsellors refused to help, so Aaron had to abandon the backpack by the track with the intention of collecting it a couple of days later when they trekked back over the trail. Because all students had to carry their own food, Aaron wouldn't have access to his rations.
亚伦继续绊倒。有一次，当他试图爬过峡谷时，他滑倒了，下巴撞在岩石上，划开了一个口子。亚伦在日记中写道：“我被痛苦包围了。工作人员似乎一点也不在乎。”此后，亚伦开始流鼻血。他继续感到强烈的寒冷。在严重摔倒两天后，亚伦说他再也背不动背包了。重量太重了，他已经没有力气背着它徒步了。辅导员拒绝帮忙，所以亚伦不得不把背包丢在小路上，打算几天后他们沿原路返回时再取回。因为所有学生都必须携带自己的食物，亚伦将无法获得他的口粮。
As punishment, the counsellors also confiscated his sleeping bag. The counsellors also confiscated his sleeping bag. Over the next couple of days, Aaron tried to quell his hunger by eating things he and other students scavenged from the terrain – a raw lizard and a cooked scorpion. He hiked a little better without his pack, but still fell again, breaking a large water container he was carrying for the group. His situation started to improve later on Thursday March 17 when he got his pack back. He was able to cook some rations and he got through that day's hike with no falls. Falls. In his journal, he described it as, My first good day here at Northstar.
作为惩罚，辅导员还没收了他的睡袋。辅导员还没收了他的睡袋。接下来的几天里，亚伦试图通过吃他和学生们从地形中搜寻到的东西来平息饥饿——一只生蜥蜴和一只煮熟的蝎子。没有背包他徒步得好了一些，但还是再次摔倒，打碎了他为小组携带的一个大水桶。3月17日星期四晚些时候，当他拿回背包时，他的情况开始好转。他能够煮一些口粮，并且在没有摔倒的情况下完成了当天的徒步。他在日记中将其描述为：“我在北极星的第一个好日子。”
But the next day, Aaron struggled to cross a chest-deep stream with the rest of the group. He lacked the strength to lift his pack over his head to prevent it getting wet, so it and all of its contents were soaked. That night he sat cold and shivering on the fringes of the group. He wasn't allowed near the fire for warmth and had to sleep in a wet sleeping bag. Aaron wrote of how scared and sick he felt in his journal. The pages were dotted with blood from his frequent nosebleeds and his handwriting was starting to become illegible. Over the next few days, things worsened. Aaron had his sleeping bag confiscated again for lack of cooperation. He only had a wool blanket for warmth and was
但第二天，亚伦在与小组其他人一起穿过一条齐胸深的溪流时挣扎。他没有力气把背包举过头顶以防止它弄湿，所以背包和里面的所有东西都湿透了。那天晚上，他冷得发抖，坐在小组的边缘。他不被允许靠近火堆取暖，不得不睡在湿透的睡袋里。亚伦在日记中写下了他感到多么害怕和恶心。页面上点缀着他频繁流鼻血留下的血迹，他的笔迹也开始变得难以辨认。接下来的几天里，情况恶化了。亚伦因为不配合再次被没收了睡袋。他只有一条羊毛毯子取暖，并且
forced to sleep away from the rest of the group who huddled together near the fire and beneath a tarpaulin. He was also barred from eating after failing to light a fire and went multiple days without food. Starving and still suffering intense stomach pain, Aaron started to lose control of his bladder. He began urinating himself during the night. Then, as the group was setting out on the ninth day of the hike, Aaron accidentally defecated in his pants. He hadn't even felt the need to go to the toilet, it had just happened without warning.
被迫睡在小组其他成员之外，他们挤在火堆旁和防水布下。他还因为没能生火而被禁止进食，并且多天没有食物。饥肠辘辘且仍然遭受剧烈胃痛的亚伦开始失去对膀胱的控制。他开始在夜间尿床。然后，当小组在徒步的第九天出发时，亚伦不小心在裤子里排便了。他甚至没有感觉到上厕所的需要，它就这样毫无预兆地发生了。
When Aaron confided in 21-year-old Jeff Hohenstein, the most experienced of the three counsellors, Jeff yelled to another counsellor, hey, he took a dump in his pants. The other counsellors and group members laughed. Aaron told the counsellors that he was sick and needed medical attention, but they ignored his pleas and accused him of faking it. They told Aaron his incontinence was proof he had no self-respect. Aaron wrote in his journal, I am in terrible condition here. My hands are all chapped and my lips are cracking. I feel like I am losing control of my body." The next morning, Aaron wasn't allowed breakfast and instead resorted to eating some prickly pear cactus. That night, all of the students had dinner withheld as punishment for being late setting up camp.
当亚伦向21岁的杰夫·豪恩斯坦（三名辅导员中最有经验的一位）吐露心声时，杰夫对另一名辅导员大喊：“嘿，他在裤子里拉屎了。”其他辅导员和组员大笑起来。亚伦告诉辅导员他病了，需要医疗救助，但他们无视了他的恳求，指责他在装病。他们告诉亚伦，他的失禁证明他没有自尊。亚伦在日记中写道：“我在这里的情况很糟糕。我的手都裂开了，嘴唇也在开裂。我觉得我正在失去对身体的控制。”第二天早上，亚伦不被允许吃早餐，而是吃了一些仙人掌果。那天晚上，所有的学生都被扣留了晚餐，作为因搭建营地迟到而受到的惩罚。
Meanwhile, the counsellors had bacon and pork chops. Aaron wrote in his journal, All I can think about is cold and pain. I miss my family so much. My hands, my lips and my face are dead." It was his final entry. Aaron wasn't allowed to eat for the next three days as punishment for failing to keep his camp cup clean and deciding to again leave his pack behind. Another student secretly gave him some powdered milk mixed with brown sugar and he consumed more cactus as well as a tea made from pine needles. Otherwise, he had nothing. Members of the group could see how listless and flat Aaron had become. He was pale, his cheeks looked hollow, and he had grown even thinner than he already was. Aaron continued to complain about his stomach ache
与此同时，辅导员们吃了培根和猪排。亚伦在日记中写道：“我能想到的只有寒冷和痛苦。我太想念我的家人了。我的手、嘴唇和脸都麻木了。”这是他最后一篇日记。亚伦在接下来的三天里不被允许进食，作为因未能保持营地杯清洁并决定再次丢下背包而受到的惩罚。另一名学生偷偷给了他一些混合了红糖的奶粉，他还吃了更多的仙人掌以及一种用松针泡的茶。除此之外，他什么都没有。小组成员可以看到亚伦变得多么无精打采和颓废。他脸色苍白，脸颊看起来凹陷，比以前更瘦了。亚伦继续抱怨胃痛
and the cold, but the counsellors refused his requests to see a doctor. They gave him nothing at night to stay warm, despite Aaron having no sleeping bag or blanket due to leaving his pack behind. On the evening of the hike's 14th day, Lance Jagger and his business partner Bill Henry paid a visit to the group. They gave Aaron a blanket to sleep with, but refused to let him join the other group members under the shelter. The next morning Lance and Bill demanded the teenagers perform a series of exercises, including 100 jumping jacks and 100 sit-ups. Aaron could only manage 10 sit-ups by himself. The counsellors helped him do another 25. By this stage, Aaron was unable to walk much
和寒冷，但辅导员拒绝了他看医生的请求。晚上他们没给他任何东西取暖，尽管亚伦因为丢下背包而没有睡袋或毯子。徒步旅行的第14天晚上，兰斯·贾格尔和他的商业伙伴比尔·亨利（Bill Henry）拜访了该小组。他们给了亚伦一条毯子睡觉，但拒绝让他加入其他组员的遮蔽处。第二天早上，兰斯和比尔要求青少年进行一系列锻炼，包括100个开合跳和100个仰卧起坐。亚伦自己只能做10个仰卧起坐。辅导员帮他做了另外25个。到这个阶段，亚伦已经无法走动太多
and only managed to hike a total of two miles. He could hardly move unless someone else helped him stand up. The counsellors began to let him eat again, giving him some rice and lentils, but he later threw them up. When Aaron yet again complained about stomach pain on Monday March 28, the counsellors repeatedly accused him of malingering. Aaron explained that it hurt him to eat and asked to see a doctor. They told him they were a long way away from any doctors. The following day, the group had to perform a full body hygiene task which involved stripping down and washing their clothes and bathing. The other teenagers noticed how scrawny Aaron had become, later describing him as looking like a victim from a Nazi concentration camp. Aaron struggled to walk without falling down. Even lifting firewood was too difficult for him.
并且总共只勉强徒步了两英里。除非有人帮他站起来，否则他几乎无法移动。辅导员开始让他再次进食，给了他一些米饭和扁豆，但他后来吐了出来。当亚伦在3月28日星期一再次抱怨胃痛时，辅导员反复指责他装病。亚伦解释说吃东西让他很痛，并要求看医生。他们告诉他，他们离任何医生都很远。第二天，小组必须执行一项全身卫生任务，包括脱掉衣服、洗衣服和洗澡。其他青少年注意到亚伦变得多么瘦骨嶙峋，后来形容他看起来像纳粹集中营的受害者。亚伦挣扎着走路而不摔倒。即使是搬运木柴对他来说也太困难了。
He was able to eat small amounts of food, but he kept moaning and saying he was dizzy. When he looked at the sky, he hallucinated streaks of purple and flashing lights. He also told the others he was seeing spots. On Wednesday March 30, the counsellors finally requested help, radioing Northstar's emergency medical technician, Georgette Costigan. She came to the camp to check on Aaron, however, the counsellors didn't tell her of his extensive complaints or that he'd barely eaten anything or slept in a sleeping bag for days. Georgette noticed Aaron's skin was dry and flushed but didn't perform a medical exam. Figuring it was nothing serious, she refused to the counsellor's request
他能够吃少量的食物，但他不停地呻吟，说他头晕。当他看向天空时，他产生了幻觉，看到了紫色的条纹和闪烁的灯光。他还告诉其他人他看到了光点。3月30日星期三，辅导员终于请求帮助，用无线电联系了北极星的紧急医疗技术员乔治特·科斯蒂根（Georgette Costigan）。她来到营地检查亚伦，然而，辅导员没有告诉她他大量的投诉，也没有告诉她他已经好几天几乎没吃东西或睡在睡袋里了。乔治特注意到亚伦的皮肤干燥且潮红，但没有进行体检。认为没什么大碍，她拒绝了辅导员的要求
that she take Aaron back with her, instead saying she'd check on him again the next day. She gave Aaron a slice of cheese and made him promise to keep hiking. Later that evening, Aaron vomited and moaned repeatedly. Later that evening, Aaron vomited and moaned repeatedly. While the other teens sat around the fire writing in their journals, he sat alone with his head tilted to one side, his mouth open and drooling. Councillor Craig Fisher told him to stop it and mimicked him. That night, Aaron was allowed to sleep in a sleeping bag for the first time in eight nights. Before going to bed, he told Craig Fisher that he didn't want to die. Craig assured him that he wouldn't. The next morning, it took Aaron an hour to crawl the 20 feet from his sleeping bag to
让她带亚伦回去，而是说她第二天会再来看看他。她给了亚伦一片奶酪，并让他保证继续徒步。那天晚上晚些时候，亚伦呕吐并反复呻吟。那天晚上晚些时候，亚伦呕吐并反复呻吟。当其他青少年坐在火堆旁写日记时，他独自坐着，头歪向一边，嘴巴张开，流着口水。辅导员克雷格·费舍尔叫他停下来，并模仿他。那天晚上，亚伦八天来第一次被允许睡在睡袋里。睡觉前，他告诉克雷格·费舍尔他不想死。克雷格向他保证他不会死。第二天早上，亚伦花了一个小时才从睡袋爬出20英尺到
the campfire. He repeatedly fell asleep during this attempt to reach the group. The counsellors had to pick him up off the ground as he was unable to stand on his own. Once he was standing, he immediately fell over again. Aaron said that he needed to use the bathroom and was unable to make it to the latrine that the group used by himself. The counsellors carried him there, then left Aaron alone. One of the staff members radioed Mike Hill, a counsellor with another group, to ask if Aaron could be left with them, as he was unable to walk and the emergency medical technician would be visiting
营火。在这次试图回到团队的过程中，他反复睡着。辅导员不得不把他从地上扶起来，因为他自己无法站立。一旦他站起来，他立刻又摔倒了。亚伦说他需要上厕所，但无法独自走到团队使用的那个简易厕所。辅导员把他抬到那里，然后把亚伦独自留在了那里。其中一名工作人员用无线电联系了另一个小组的辅导员迈克·希尔，询问是否可以让亚伦留在他们那里，因为他无法行走，而且急救医疗技术员当天会去探望
Mike's group that day. Mike agreed and offered to collect Aaron with some of his campers. When he arrived at the primitive camp, he was shocked to discover Aaron sitting inside the latrine covered with excrement. He had fallen in and was unable to get up. One of Aaron's counsellors mocked him by imitating the way he had collapsed and told Mike that Aaron was deliberately starving himself because he wanted to die. Horrified, Mike and several of his campers lifted Aaron out of the latrine and carried him to a shady spot. Are you doing this because you want to die? Mike asked Aaron. No sir, Aaron replied. I don't want to die, sir. don't want to die, sir." Mike made Aaron some oatmeal, but he only managed to eat a few spoonfuls.
迈克的小组。迈克同意了，并提出带上他的一些营员去接亚伦。当他到达那个原始营地时，他震惊地发现亚伦坐在简易厕所里，浑身沾满了排泄物。他掉进去了，无法站起来。亚伦的一名辅导员嘲笑他，模仿他倒下的样子，并告诉迈克，亚伦是故意绝食，因为他想死。迈克和他的几名营员感到震惊，他们把亚伦从厕所里抬出来，带到了一个阴凉的地方。你这样做是因为你想死吗？迈克问亚伦。不，先生，亚伦回答说。我不想死，先生。我不想死，先生。迈克给亚伦做了些燕麦粥，但他只勉强吃了两三勺。
In a hoarse voice, he told Mike that all he could see was a white glare. A Native American man from the Apache tribe, Mike later said he knew then that Aaron was dying. He took out some Apache healing powder he kept in his pocket and sprinkled it around Aaron. Then he knelt and prayed. One of the boys camping with Mike's group began to cry. Sometime later, Mike received a message from Eric Henry, the son of North Star co-owner Bill Henry, that he was headed their way with a truck to collect Aaron. Get the faker ready, Eric said.
他用嘶哑的声音告诉迈克，他所能看到的只有一片白光。迈克后来提到，作为一名来自阿帕奇部落的美国原住民，他当时就知道亚伦快要死了。他拿出放在口袋里的一些阿帕奇治疗粉末，撒在亚伦周围。然后他跪下来祈祷。迈克小组里的一个男孩开始哭泣。过了一会儿，迈克收到了北极星联合创始人比尔·亨利的儿子埃里克·亨利发来的消息，说他正开着卡车往他们那边赶，准备接走亚伦。让那个骗子准备好，埃里克说。
When he arrived, Eric lifted Aaron into the back seat as he was unable to get up by himself, then spent about 15 minutes chatting with other staff members. Just before 3pm, they heard a banging sound coming from the truck. Aaron was slumped unconscious, his head knocked against the back window. He had no pulse, and his heart had stopped. Eric Henry and Mike Hill pulled Aaron from the car, and Eric radioed base camp while Mike tried to administer CPR. Georgette Costigan, the emergency medical technician, soon arrived at the scene and attempted to revive Aaron. She was joined by the physician's assistant who'd examined Aaron when he was first admitted to the program, but didn't recognise
当埃里克到达时，他把亚伦抱进后座，因为亚伦自己无法站起来，然后花了大约15分钟与其他工作人员聊天。下午3点前不久，他们听到卡车里传来砰砰的声音。亚伦瘫倒在座位上，失去了知觉，头撞在后窗上。他没有脉搏，心脏已经停止跳动。埃里克·亨利和迈克·希尔把亚伦从车里拉出来，埃里克用无线电联系了大本营，而迈克试图对他进行心肺复苏。急救医疗技术员乔吉特·科斯蒂根很快赶到现场，试图抢救亚伦。与她一起的还有助理医师，他曾在亚伦刚加入该项目时检查过他，但没有认出
the frail and gaunt boy in front of him. Advanced life support procedures were performed on Aaron without success. Georgette repeatedly cried out, Georgeette repeatedly cried out, Oh shit, oh shit. A helicopter was sent for, and Aaron was flown to a hospital in Page, Arizona, where he was pronounced dead. When North Star Expeditions called the Bacon family to inform them of Aaron's passing, they used vague language and implied there had been some sort of tragic accident. Bob Bacon was left with the impression that Aaron had suddenly collapsed out of the blue, perhaps after accidentally eating some kind of poisonous vegetation. But when he and Sally Bacon viewed their son's body in the morgue, they knew that whatever had happened was no sudden accident.
眼前这个虚弱消瘦的男孩。他们对亚伦进行了高级生命支持程序，但没有成功。乔吉特反复大喊，乔吉特反复大喊，该死，该死。他们叫来了直升机，亚伦被空运到亚利桑那州佩奇市的一家医院，在那里被宣布死亡。当北极星探险公司打电话给培根一家通知他们亚伦去世的消息时，他们使用了含糊的语言，暗示发生了一场某种悲剧性的事故。鲍勃·培根以为亚伦是突然倒下的，也许是在不小心吃了某种有毒植物之后。但当他和萨莉·培根在停尸房看到儿子的遗体时，他们知道无论发生了什么，绝不是什么突发的意外。
In the month since they had last seen Aaron, their son had grown so emaciated while his skin from his groin to his feet was covered in weeping, open sores. The only way that they could recognise him was from a childhood scar above his right eye. Sally and Bob were horrified that stuff from Northstar had given them no warning about the state their son's body was in or what they might see when they identified him. An autopsy revealed that during the four weeks he'd been at the camp, Aaron's weight had dropped from 131 pounds or 59 kilograms to 108 pounds, just under 49 kilograms. This amounted to a 17% loss of body mass. Many of the bruises covering his skin were from the repeated falls he'd suffered. Others were from the staff members' resuscitation attempts.
在他们上次见到亚伦的一个月里，他们的儿子变得如此消瘦，从腹股沟到脚部的皮肤上布满了渗液的开放性溃疡。他们唯一能认出他的方式是他右眼上方的一个童年伤疤。萨莉和鲍勃感到震惊，北极星的工作人员竟然没有给他们任何关于儿子身体状况的警告，也没有告诉他们在认尸时可能会看到什么。尸检显示，在他在营地的四周里，亚伦的体重从131磅（59公斤）下降到了108磅（不到49公斤）。这相当于损失了17%的体重。他皮肤上覆盖的许多淤青是他反复摔倒造成的。其他的则是工作人员试图抢救时留下的。
The sores from his groin down were the result of Aaron's incontinence, which he'd endured over the final two weeks of his life. Aaron had ultimately died of acute peritonitis, an inflammation of the membrane that lines the abdominal wall. This inflammation is caused most commonly by bacterial infection. In Aaron's case, it was the result of a perforated ulcer in his large intestine which allowed the contents of his digestive system to leak into his abdominal cavity. Despite Northstar staff saying Aaron's demise had been sudden, the infection was large and extensive, indicating it had been growing over a long period. It was estimated that the ulcer had most likely developed around Tuesday March 15, about two
他腹股沟以下的溃疡是亚伦失禁的结果，他在生命的最后两周里一直忍受着这种痛苦。亚伦最终死于急性腹膜炎，这是腹壁内膜的炎症。这种炎症最常见的原因是细菌感染。在亚伦的案例中，这是大肠穿孔溃疡的结果，导致他消化系统的内容物泄漏到腹腔中。尽管北极星的工作人员称亚伦的死亡是突然的，但感染范围很大且广泛，表明它已经生长了很长一段时间。据估计，溃疡很可能是在3月15日星期二左右形成的，大约在
weeks after Aaron's arrival at Northstar. Hypothermia, stress, and malnutrition would have all caused the ulcer to worsen. Aaron had been complaining of stomach pain since almost the beginning of his time at Northstar. If the ulcer had been diagnosed early on, it could have been cured by an over-the-counter medication. If Aaron had been taken to hospital as late as the day before his death or even hours before his final collapse, his life would most likely have been saved by antibiotics and proper medical care. A few days after the Bacon's viewed their son's body, they received a call at home from a television reporter who was also based in
亚伦到达北极星两周后。体温过低、压力和营养不良都会导致溃疡恶化。亚伦几乎从他待在北极星的初期就开始抱怨胃痛。如果溃疡能及早诊断出来，本可以通过非处方药治愈。如果亚伦在去世前一天甚至在最后一次倒下前几小时被送往医院，他的生命很可能通过抗生素和适当的医疗护理得到挽救。在培根夫妇看到儿子遗体的几天后，他们在家中接到了当地一位电视记者的电话，该记者也常驻
Phoenix and was covering Aaron's death for their station. The reporter was seeking a statement from the couple about the fact that four years earlier two other teenagers had died in incidents at two separate Utah-based wilderness therapy programs, both of which had direct links to North Star expeditions. In mid-1990, California couple Cathy and Bob Sutton were desperate to help their daughter, 15-year-old Michelle. Michelle had been cheerful, creative and trusting, but her life was upended one night when she was hanging out with friends.
凤凰城，并正在为他们的电视台报道亚伦的死亡事件。记者寻求这对夫妇发表声明，因为四年前，两名青少年在犹他州两个独立的荒野治疗项目中死亡，这两个项目都与北极星探险公司有直接联系。1990年中期，加州夫妇凯茜和鲍勃·萨顿急于帮助他们15岁的女儿米歇尔。米歇尔曾经开朗、有创造力且信任他人，但有一天晚上她和朋友出去玩时，她的生活被彻底颠覆了。
She had been sitting in a truck with a boy she knew from school when he sexually assaulted and raped her. Michelle confided in her parents who took her to hospital for an examination and helped Michelle report the rape to the police. But the boy was never charged. Michelle struggled in the aftermath of the rape and her pain was exacerbated by having to see her rapist at school every day. Her mother Cathy began to suspect that Michelle was experiencing suicidal thoughts. It was clear to the Satans that their daughter needed help. They tried a few different measures including speaking to the pastor at their church. Soon a family friend told them about something that might help. There was a wilderness therapy
她当时和学校认识的一个男孩坐在卡车里，那个男孩对她进行了性侵犯和强奸。米歇尔向父母吐露了实情，他们带她去医院检查，并帮助米歇尔向警方报案。但那个男孩从未被起诉。强奸事件发生后，米歇尔陷入了挣扎，每天在学校见到强奸犯让她痛苦加剧。她的母亲凯茜开始怀疑米歇尔有自杀倾向。萨顿夫妇很清楚，他们的女儿需要帮助。他们尝试了几种不同的方法，包括与教会的牧师交谈。很快，一位家庭朋友告诉他们一些可能有帮助的事情。有一个荒野治疗
program in St George, Utah called SummitQuest that had been started by a woman named Gayle Palmer. Gayle had created the program to help teens who were struggling with issues just like Michelle. Although they were initially reluctant to send their daughter away, the Sutton's eventually realised that Michelle needed help that they weren't equipped to provide. Cathy contacted Gail Palmer for more information. Gail was empathetic and compassionate. She explained that Summit Quest had been running for two years and had many satisfied customers whose testimonials were provided. The program ran for 63 days and taught teens how to survive
项目位于犹他州圣乔治，名叫“巅峰探索”（SummitQuest），是由一位名叫盖尔·帕尔默的女性创办的。盖尔创办这个项目是为了帮助像米歇尔这样正面临困境的青少年。虽然他们最初不愿把女儿送走，但萨顿夫妇最终意识到，米歇尔需要的帮助是他们无法提供的。凯茜联系了盖尔·帕尔默以获取更多信息。盖尔表现得富有同情心和怜悯心。她解释说，“巅峰探索”已经运营了两年，有很多满意的客户，并提供了推荐信。该项目为期63天，教导青少年如何在
in the wilderness. They would be led by trained survival experts who would help them build their self-esteem. Gale said that while the program was challenging, it was also safe and supportive. There were doctors, nurses, a nutritionist and psychologist all on site who would be able to help Michelle. As well as addressing physical stamina, the program built mental resilience and spiritual strength. Over the course of several weeks, Cathy spoke with Gayle Palmer 21 times. After asking every question she could think of and addressing all of her potential doubts, Kathy was convinced that SummitQuest could help Michelle regain her sense of self. She paid Gale $13,900 for Michelle's
荒野中生存。他们将由训练有素的生存专家带领，帮助他们建立自尊。盖尔说，虽然这个项目很有挑战性，但它也是安全和支持性的。现场有医生、护士、营养师和心理学家，他们都能帮助米歇尔。除了锻炼身体耐力外，该项目还建立了心理韧性和精神力量。在几周的时间里，凯茜与盖尔·帕尔默通了21次电话。在问了所有能想到的问题并解决了所有潜在的疑虑后，凯茜确信“巅峰探索”能帮助米歇尔找回自我。她向盖尔支付了13,900美元作为米歇尔的
enrolment. Michelle was agreeable to the plan because she wanted to both heal and get away from the boy who raped her. She left California and started the Summit Quest program on Tuesday May 1 1990. Nine days later, Michelle was dead. During an exercise, her group's counsellors had gotten lost, prolonging a hike in the stifling summer heat. Their radios were broken, leaving them unable to call for assistance, and water supplies were limited. When Michelle ran out of her allocated water supply, councillors told the other group members not to share their water with her, not even when she started throwing up, falling down and complaining that her vision was blurry.
入学费用。米歇尔同意了这个计划，因为她既想治愈自己，又想远离那个强奸她的男孩。她离开加州，于1990年5月1日星期二开始了“巅峰探索”项目。九天后，米歇尔死了。在一次训练中，她小组的辅导员迷路了，导致在闷热的夏日里徒步时间延长。他们的无线电坏了，无法呼叫救援，水供应也很有限。当米歇尔用完了分配的水时，辅导员告诉其他小组成员不要和她分享水，即使在她开始呕吐、摔倒并抱怨视力模糊时也是如此。
Even as Michelle became so dehydrated that her mouth appeared white and crusty, her counsellors accused her of faking her symptoms and joked that it looked like she had been eating marshmallows. After hiking over a mountain late on the afternoon of Wednesday March 9, Michelle collapsed and died of dehydration. Summit Quest councillors couldn't alert base camp due to their broken radios, so instead they had to light signal fires to get attention. It was 18 hours until a passing plane spotted them and sent help. Gale Palmer subsequently smeared the girl's name by saying Michelle had smuggled cocaine into
即使米歇尔脱水到嘴唇发白结痂，她的辅导员仍指责她在装病，并开玩笑说她看起来像是在吃棉花糖。3月9日星期三下午晚些时候翻过一座山后，米歇尔倒下并死于脱水。“巅峰探索”的辅导员因无线电损坏无法通知大本营，所以他们不得不点燃信号火来引起注意。直到18小时后，一架路过的飞机发现了他们并派出了救援。盖尔·帕尔默随后通过声称米歇尔将可卡因走私到
Summit Quest and died of a drug overdose, not dehydration. These claims were entirely false. No criminal charges were ever laid against Gale, but the Sutton's later sued SummitQuest and reached a partial settlement for $345,000 in 1992. The settlement money was paid by SummitQuest's insurer. Despite Gale Palmer's assertions that SummitQuest attendees had access to a psychologist, no actual therapy was ever provided by the wilderness therapy program. The camp counsellors weren't experts in adolescent development or wilderness survival. They were mostly college students being paid minimum wage.
“巅峰探索”并死于药物过量而非脱水来抹黑这个女孩。这些说法完全是虚假的。盖尔从未受到任何刑事指控，但萨顿夫妇后来起诉了“巅峰探索”，并于1992年达成了345,000美元的部分和解。和解金由“巅峰探索”的保险公司支付。尽管盖尔·帕尔默声称“巅峰探索”的参与者可以接触到心理学家，但该荒野治疗项目从未提供过任何实际的治疗。营地辅导员不是青少年发展或荒野生存方面的专家。他们大多是拿最低工资的大学生。
Although Gale had told Cathy Sutton that SummitQuest was two years old, in reality it was brand new and Michelle's group was their first ever. SummitQuest was operating under a 90-day provisional license and Gale Palmer wasn't an experienced survivalist or child health expert. Prior to launching SummitQuest, she had worked in the admissions office for another wilderness therapy program. The testimonials from satisfied parents and teens that she'd shared with Kathy Sutton had been taken from that business, which was called Challenger. Challenger was founded in 1987 by entrepreneur Steve Cardasano after a career in the military. Steve Cardasano was a member of the Church of Jesus Christ of
虽然盖尔告诉凯茜·萨顿“巅峰探索”已经有两年历史了，但实际上它是全新的，米歇尔的小组是他们的第一批学员。当时“巅峰探索”在90天临时执照下运营，盖尔·帕尔默也不是经验丰富的生存专家或儿童健康专家。在创办“巅峰探索”之前，她曾在另一个荒野治疗项目的招生办公室工作。她与凯茜·萨顿分享的那些满意家长和青少年的推荐信都是从那家名为“挑战者”（Challenger）的企业那里拿来的。“挑战者”由企业家史蒂夫·卡达萨诺于1987年创立，他此前有军旅生涯。史蒂夫·卡达萨诺是耶稣基督后期圣徒教会的成员，
Latter-day Saints and a former student at Utah's Brigham Young University. In the 1970s, BYU introduced its own wilderness therapy program for college students. This course lasted several weeks, taught basic survival skills and encouraged students to reflect on their goals while living in the wilderness. It was very successful until 1975 when a female participant died of dehydration. After that, BYU ceased offering the program. Steve Cardasano had completed the program when he was a student and had loved it. His experience inspired him to start his own program aimed at younger participants in Escalante, Utah. He dubbed it Challenger and it set the benchmark for what the wilderness therapy industry would become in Utah and surrounding states. Teenagers had to complete arduous hikes,
也是犹他州杨百翰大学的前学生。20世纪70年代，杨百翰大学为大学生推出了自己的荒野治疗项目。该课程持续数周，教授基本的生存技能，并鼓励学生在荒野生活时反思自己的目标。它非常成功，直到1975年一名女性参与者死于脱水。此后，杨百翰大学停止提供该项目。史蒂夫·卡达萨诺在学生时代完成了该项目，并非常喜欢它。他的经历激励他在犹他州埃斯卡兰特创办了自己的项目，目标是更年轻的参与者。他将其命名为“挑战者”，它为犹他州及周边地区的荒野治疗行业树立了标杆。青少年必须完成艰苦的徒步旅行，
were given scant food and water and were verbally berated under the guise of tough love. Councillors were taught to distrust the teens they led, with Steve Cardasano describing them as master manipulators who would feign injuries or illness to get out of the program. Challenger quickly took off, thanks in part to Steve Cardasano's decision to promote the program on daytime television talk shows such as Sally Jessie Raphael and Heraldo. Many parents in the late 1980s and early 90s harboured concerns about their children ending up on the wrong path. This was due in part to moral panics around drug use, street gangs, and supposed satanic cults.
被给予少量的食物和水，并以“严厉的爱”为幌子受到言语辱骂。辅导员被教导要不信任他们带领的青少年，史蒂夫·卡达萨诺将他们描述为操纵大师，会假装受伤或生病以逃避项目。“挑战者”迅速走红，部分归功于史蒂夫·卡达萨诺决定在日间电视脱口秀节目（如《萨莉·杰西·拉斐尔》和《赫拉尔多》）上推广该项目。20世纪80年代末和90年代初，许多家长担心自己的孩子走上歧途。这在一定程度上是由于围绕吸毒、街头帮派和所谓的撒旦崇拜的道德恐慌。
Steve Cardasano's message reached a lot of concerned parents who were desperate to help their children. Many took out second mortgages so they could afford the $15,900 price tag. Challenger was cheap to run. All that was required were some camping equipment and low-cost foods like oats and lentils. Steve Cardasano also set the model for hiring young people to work as counselors and paying them minimum wage. With lots of money coming in and very little going out, Challenger made $3.2 million in its first year of operation. After Gail Palmer started her own wilderness therapy program which resulted in Michelle Sutton's death, Steve Cardasano publicly accused his ex-employee of criminal negligence, telling journalists. At Challenger, a tragedy
史蒂夫·卡达萨诺的信息触及了许多急于帮助孩子的忧心忡忡的家长。许多人抵押了房产以支付15,900美元的费用。“挑战者”的运营成本很低。所需要的只是露营设备和燕麦、扁豆等低成本食物。史蒂夫·卡达萨诺还确立了雇佣年轻人担任辅导员并支付最低工资的模式。由于收入丰厚而支出极少，“挑战者”在运营的第一年就赚了320万美元。在盖尔·帕尔默创办了自己的荒野治疗项目并导致米歇尔·萨顿死亡后，史蒂夫·卡达萨诺公开指责他的前员工犯有刑事疏忽，并告诉记者。在“挑战者”，像杀死米歇尔·萨顿那样的悲剧
like the one that killed Michelle Sutton could never happen. Six weeks later, 16-year-old Kristen Chase left her home in Florida to attend Challenger. She wasn't given a physical exam upon being admitted to the program, but her mother did provide them with extensive medical records, which included difficulty running, a knee injury, and a history of coughing up blood. On Tuesday, June 26, just a few days into her program, Kristin collapsed after a five-mile hike. Christian collapsed after a five mile hike. Councillors had dismissed Christian's complaints of feeling unwell, denied her water and ridiculed her. Christian died of exertional heatstroke. It took more than two hours for help to arrive. This time authorities in Utah laid criminal charges.
永远不会发生。六周后，16岁的克里斯汀·蔡斯离开佛罗里达的家前往“挑战者”。她在加入项目时没有接受体检，但她的母亲确实向他们提供了详尽的医疗记录，其中包括跑步困难、膝盖受伤和咳血史。6月26日星期二，在项目开始仅几天后，克里斯汀在一次五英里徒步后倒下。克里斯汀在一次五英里徒步后倒下。辅导员无视了克里斯汀关于身体不适的抱怨，拒绝给她水并嘲笑她。克里斯汀死于劳累性中暑。救援人员花了两个多小时才赶到。这一次，犹他州的当局提起了刑事指控。
Kane County prosecutors charged Steve Cardasano and an employee who went by the name Horsehair with negligent homicide and nine counts of child abuse relating to Kristin and other challenger attendees. Horsehair subsequently agreed to testify against Cardisano in exchange for having his own charges dismissed. At Cardisano's trial, more than a year later, in September 1991, Challenger employees gave evidence that students were beaten and treated abusively while under their care. But before the jury could deliberate, a mistrial was called due to the judge having failed to read the charges to them at the beginning of the trial. Eight months later,
凯恩县检察官以过失杀人罪和九项虐待儿童罪对史蒂夫·卡达萨诺和一名绰号为“马毛”（Horsehair）的员工提起诉讼，罪名涉及克里斯汀和其他“挑战者”学员。随后，“马毛”同意出庭指控卡达萨诺，以换取撤销对他自己的指控。一年多后的1991年9月，在卡达萨诺的审判中，“挑战者”的员工提供了证据，证明学生在他们的照看下遭到殴打和虐待。但在陪审团能够审议之前，由于法官在审判开始时未能向他们宣读指控，审判被宣布无效。八个月后，
there was a retrial. The jury ultimately acquitted Steve Cardasano after determining that the prosecution hadn't done enough to prove he was guilty. One juror later spoke out, saying that they had all agreed there were issues with the program. Steve Cardizzano had actually told one former staffer that it was inevitable some teens undertaking wilderness programs would die. He'd referred to this likelihood as a window of loss, stating, we're going to help so many kids that it's worth the loss of a few. An ongoing problem with Utah's wilderness therapy programs was the lack of state regulation and oversight. Wilderness therapy falls under a broader category of behaviour modification facilities known collectively as the troubled teen industry. Aimed at parents who have concerns
进行了重审。陪审团最终在确定检方没有提供足够的证据证明他有罪后，判决史蒂夫·卡达萨诺无罪。一名陪审员后来公开表示，他们都同意该项目存在问题。史蒂夫·卡达萨诺实际上曾告诉一名员工，一些参加荒野项目的青少年死亡是不可避免的。他将这种可能性称为“损失窗口”，并表示：“我们将帮助这么多孩子，以至于损失几个也是值得的。”犹他州荒野治疗项目的一个持续存在的问题是缺乏州政府的监管和监督。荒野治疗属于行为矫正设施的更广泛类别，统称为“问题青少年行业”。针对有顾虑的家长
about their adolescent children's behaviour, these facilities take many forms. They can be boot camps, treatment centres, or wilderness therapy. They're also marketed as being able to solve numerous issues the parents may be worried about, including drug use, sexuality, behaviour deemed disrespectful, or playing too many video games. When Steve Cardasano started Challenger, the troubled teen industry was a burgeoning one. There were no federal laws in place to regulate it, meaning the situation varied from state to state. In January 1990, new regulations were drafted in Utah, dictating that all wilderness therapy
关于他们青少年子女的行为，这些设施有多种形式。它们可以是训练营、治疗中心或荒野治疗。它们也被推销为能够解决家长可能担心的许多问题，包括吸毒、性行为、被认为不尊重的行为或玩太多电子游戏。当史蒂夫·卡达萨诺创办“挑战者”时，问题青少年行业正处于萌芽阶段。当时没有联邦法律来监管它，这意味着情况因州而异。1990年1月，犹他州起草了新法规，规定所有荒野治疗
participants must first pass a physical exam by a doctor and be provided with a minimum amount of water each day. Michelle Sutton and Kristin Chase both died shortly before these regulations were set to take effect in July 1990. In the wake of their deaths, the state of Utah passed a law requiring all wilderness therapy programs to be licensed by the Department of their deaths, the state of Utah passed a law requiring all wilderness therapy programs to be licensed by the Department of Health and Human Services and also began drafting stricter regulations. They were helped in this by some who'd worked within the industry, including ex-challenger employee Horsehair. At the same time, Horsehair, whose real name was Lance Jagger, decided to start his own wilderness therapy program alongside fellow former Challenger colleague
参与者必须首先通过医生的体检，并每天获得最低限度的饮用水。米歇尔·萨顿和克里斯汀·蔡斯都在这些法规于1990年7月生效前不久死亡。在她们去世后，犹他州通过了一项法律，要求所有荒野治疗项目必须获得卫生与公众服务部的许可，并开始起草更严格的法规。一些曾在该行业工作过的人，包括前“挑战者”员工“马毛”，也为此提供了帮助。与此同时，“马毛”（真名兰斯·贾格尔）决定与前“挑战者”同事
Bill Henry. In October 1990, the two men were granted a license by the state of Utah to begin their new business. North Star Expeditions. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Struggling to decide what's for dinner often leads to expensive, unsatisfying takeout. Home Chef provides an easy alternative with quick, affordable and delicious meal kits. The simplicity and minimal prep make it ideal for anyone, even if you're not confident in the kitchen.
比尔·亨利一起创办自己的荒野治疗项目。1990年10月，两人获得了犹他州颁发的执照，开始经营他们的新业务：北极星探险公司。Casefile节目稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商来支持我们。纠结晚餐吃什么通常会导致昂贵且不令人满意的外卖。Home Chef提供了一种简单的替代方案，提供快速、实惠且美味的餐包。其简单性和极少的准备工作使其非常适合任何人，即使您对厨艺没有信心。
Home Chef offers meal kits for every level of cook, from classic kits with pre-portioned ingredients and simple instructions to speedy recipes ready in under 30 minutes. You can choose oven-ready kits with pre-chopped ingredients or quick microwave meals that come together in minutes. Home Chef has something for everyone, ensuring delicious meals without the stress. Home Chef has over 30 options a week and serves a variety of dietary needs. They even have a delicious kid-friendly family menu, which is picky eater approved and takes the stress out of dinnertime. Not only is Home Chef convenient, it's economical too.
Home Chef为各个水平的厨师提供餐包，从配有预分量食材和简单说明的经典餐包，到30分钟内即可完成的快速食谱。您可以选择配有预切食材的烤箱餐包，或几分钟内即可完成的快速微波炉餐。Home Chef为每个人提供选择，确保美味的餐点而无需压力。Home Chef每周有超过30种选择，满足各种饮食需求。他们甚至有美味的儿童友好型家庭菜单，深受挑食者喜爱，消除了晚餐时间的压力。Home Chef不仅方便，而且经济实惠。
Their customers save an average of $86 per month on groceries. Olivia LaVoice, host of Casefile Presents series The Bakersfield 3, is loving Home Chef for its convenience and the high quality of ingredients supplied. She says it's also introduced her to new recipes she wouldn't have otherwise made. For a limited time, Home Chef is offering my listeners 18 free meals plus free dessert for life and of course free shipping on your first box. Go to homechef.com That's homechef.com slash casefile for 18 free meals and free dessert for life. You heard that right. Homechef.com slash casefile. Must be an active subscriber to receive free dessert.
他们的客户平均每月在杂货上节省86美元。Casefile Presents系列《贝克斯菲尔德3》的主持人奥利维亚·拉沃伊斯非常喜欢Home Chef的便利性和所提供食材的高品质。她说它还向她介绍了她以前不会做的新食谱。在有限的时间内，Home Chef为我的听众提供18份免费餐点，外加终身免费甜点，当然还有首个餐盒免费送货。请访问homechef.com，即homechef.com/casefile，即可获得18份免费餐点和终身免费甜点。你没听错。Homechef.com/casefile。必须是活跃订阅者才能获得免费甜点。
Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. receive free dessert. Aaron Bacon's parents had not known about the earlier wilderness therapy deaths, let alone that Lance Jagger was criminally charged for one. Four days after Aaron died, he was buried in his hometown of Phoenix on Monday, April 4. A few days later, Sally and Bob Bacon drove to Utah to see the location where he had died. They also met with the county sheriff, deputy sheriff, and the county prosecutor. Bob asked whether his son's death would be investigated.
感谢您收听本集的广告。获得免费甜点。亚伦·培根的父母并不知道早先发生的荒野治疗死亡事件，更不知道兰斯·贾格尔曾因其中一起事件受到刑事指控。亚伦去世四天后，他于4月4日星期一被安葬在家乡凤凰城。几天后，萨莉和鲍勃·培根开车前往犹他州，查看他去世的地点。他们还与县治安官、副治安官和县检察官会面。鲍勃询问他儿子的死因是否会进行调查。
The prosecutor said that it would. When the police first arrived at North Star following Aaron's passing, they hadn't believed that the death was suspicious. All of the North Star employees and staff they spoke to said that Aaron collapsed out of the blue. Staff members had made every effort to revive him. But the investigators were aware that Aaron's death was the third time a teenager had died while enrolled in a Utah wilderness therapy program. Consequently, they would have to look into the circumstances very carefully, even if nothing seemed amiss. Aaron's fellow campers were asked to provide written statements about his death, and the Deputy Sheriff Celeste
检察官表示会进行调查。当警方在亚伦去世后首次抵达北极星时，他们并不认为这起死亡事件可疑。他们交谈过的所有北极星员工和工作人员都说亚伦是突然倒下的。工作人员已尽一切努力抢救他。但调查人员意识到，亚伦的死亡是第三次有青少年在参加犹他州荒野治疗项目时死亡。因此，即使看起来没有什么不对劲，他们也必须非常仔细地调查情况。亚伦的营友被要求提供关于他死亡的书面陈述，副治安官塞莱斯特·
Bernards also seized their journals. She also had Aaron's own journal in her possession. The picture painted by Aaron's words was vastly different to one given by camp counsellors. According to Aaron's version of events, he had been complaining about ill health since almost the start of the program, only to be mocked, dismissed, and even punished. Over the next few months, Deputy Bernardes carefully scrutinised the other students' journals. They had also written about Aaron's deteriorating health and how he had been treated, and their descriptions matched his. Deputy Bernard's added up crucial details in their
伯纳德还查封了他们的日记。她手中还有亚伦自己的日记。亚伦笔下描绘的画面与营地辅导员提供的画面截然不同。根据亚伦的说法，他几乎从项目开始就一直在抱怨身体不适，结果却遭到嘲笑、无视，甚至惩罚。在接下来的几个月里，伯纳德副治安官仔细审查了其他学生的日记。他们也写到了亚伦不断恶化的健康状况以及他受到的待遇，他们的描述与他的相符。伯纳德副治安官在他们的
accounts, such as how Aaron was punished by having food withheld. During interviews, the other teenagers in Aaron's group said that sometimes they'd tried to help him by sneaking in food and sharing their blankets, but usually they were too scared to do so due to the punishments that would follow if caught. Deputy Bernards cross-checked the campers' claims against provable data, such as what the temperature and weather conditions were during Arren's month at Northstar. She calculated that Arren had been forced to sleep 14 nights in the desert without a sleeping bag. For four of these nights, he didn't even have a blanket. He had been deprived of food entirely for a total of 11 days. These punishments were in direct violation of Northstar's own code
叙述中汇总了关键细节，例如亚伦是如何通过被扣留食物来受到惩罚的。在采访中，亚伦小组里的其他青少年说，有时他们试图通过偷偷塞食物和分享毯子来帮助他，但通常他们因为害怕被发现后会受到惩罚而不敢这样做。伯纳德副治安官将营员们的说法与可证明的数据进行了交叉核对，例如亚伦在北极星待的那一个月里的气温和天气状况。她计算出亚伦被迫在沙漠中睡了14个晚上，没有睡袋。其中四个晚上，他甚至连毯子都没有。他总共有11天完全被剥夺了食物。这些惩罚直接违反了北极星自己的行为准则。
of conduct. When they were hired, every counsellor at Northstar received a copy of the company's policies and procedures manual which they had to read and sign. A page titled, Discipline and Treatment of the Student, read in part. The following is not appropriate treatment of a student and his grounds for dismissal. The withholding of any meal. Denial of clothing, shelter or bedding. Failure to provide adequate medical care and or treatment. to provide adequate medical care and or treatment. Verbal abuse using language which attacks the well-being of the student. This may include, but is not limited to, name-calling, teasing, humiliation, ridicule, use of foul and abusive language, etc. Deputy Bernard's looked into Northstar's finances. The business grossed roughly $1.68 million per year, with between $1 and $1.5 million
在被录用时，北极星的每位辅导员都收到了一份公司政策和程序手册，他们必须阅读并签字。一份标题为“学生的纪律与待遇”的页面部分写道：以下是不适当的学生待遇，是解雇的理由。扣留任何餐点。拒绝提供衣物、住所或床上用品。未能提供足够的医疗护理和/或治疗。言语虐待，使用攻击学生福祉的语言。这可能包括但不限于辱骂、戏弄、羞辱、嘲笑、使用粗俗和辱骂性语言等。伯纳德副治安官调查了北极星的财务状况。该业务每年总收入约为168万美元，其中100万到150万美元
being pure profit. They were able to make this much thanks to their minor outlays and under-qualified staff. Despite Northstar assuring parents that all their staff were trained in therapy and wilderness skills, most camp counsellors they hired were barely out of school and hadn't undergone criminal background checks. They also claimed to have a camp psychologist named Doc Dave who was on hand to help kids. In reality, Doc Dave was a social worker who only met the teens once when they first arrived at Northstar. Investigators were concerned about the conditions teenagers at Northstar were being forced to endure. The camp had been checked in the weeks after Aaron died and was found to be fully complying
是纯利润。他们之所以能赚这么多钱，多亏了他们微小的支出和不合格的员工。尽管北极星向家长保证他们所有的员工都接受过治疗和荒野技能培训，但他们雇佣的大多数营地辅导员几乎刚出校门，也没有接受过犯罪背景调查。他们还声称有一位名叫“戴夫医生”的营地心理学家，随时准备帮助孩子们。实际上，戴夫医生是一名社会工作者，他只在青少年刚到达北极星时见过他们一次。调查人员对北极星的青少年被迫忍受的条件感到担忧。营地在亚伦去世后的几周内接受了检查，被发现完全符合
with Utah's regulations, but the police still had their doubts. In early September, they conducted a surprise inspection of Northstar's headquarters, with two doctors, a psychologist and a nurse examining the 21 adolescents who were in their care. They determined that three girls staying with Northstar weren't well enough to continue with the program. They were removed and had to stay with foster families until their guardians could take them home. Northstar continued to operate for its other campers. When LA Times journalist Joe Morgenstein contacted Northstar co-founder Lance Jagger following this development, he described the inspection as a witch hunt. He thought it was ridiculous that investigators were listening to, quote, solely the words of the kids.
犹他州的法规，但警方仍有疑虑。9月初，他们对北极星总部进行了突击检查，两名医生、一名心理学家和一名护士检查了他们照看的21名青少年。他们确定，留在北极星的三名女孩身体状况不足以继续该项目。她们被带走，必须寄宿在寄养家庭，直到她们的监护人能带她们回家。北极星继续为其其他营员运营。当《洛杉矶时报》记者乔·摩根斯坦在这一进展后联系北极星联合创始人兰斯·贾格尔时，他将这次检查描述为“猎巫行动”。他认为调查人员只听取“仅仅是孩子们的话”是荒谬的。
North Star representatives were adamant that there was no way they could have known about Aaron's condition. One spokesperson even claimed he hadn't been deprived of food, but instead rejected the food offered to him. Co-owner Bill Henry blamed Aaron Bacon's cannabis usage for his death, insisting he must have had his ulcer for a long time, but his history of smoking pot must have masked the pain. Joe Morgenstein fact-checked this claim with doctors, who said that nothing could have covered the pain of a perforated ulcer. Just over a month after the surprise inspection of Northstar, prosecutors charged Lance Jagger, Bill Henry, and six of their employees with felony child abuse charges.
北极星的代表坚称他们不可能知道亚伦的状况。一位发言人甚至声称他没有被剥夺食物，而是拒绝了提供给他的食物。联合创始人比尔·亨利将亚伦·培根的死亡归咎于他使用大麻，坚称他的溃疡一定存在了很长时间，但他吸食大麻的历史一定掩盖了疼痛。乔·摩根斯坦向医生核实了这一说法，医生表示，没有什么能掩盖穿孔性溃疡的疼痛。在对北极星进行突击检查一个多月后，检察官对兰斯·贾格尔、比尔·亨利及其六名员工提起了重罪虐待儿童指控。
Georgette Costigan, the camp's emergency medical technician, was also charged with witness tampering. According to Mike Hill, the counsellor for another group who had tried to help Aaron in his final moments, she had tried to convince some of the students to revise their written statements for the Sheriff's Office to make them look less incriminating. These charges against Georgette Costigan were later dropped due to a lack of evidence. The prosecutors had other problems that would make pursuing the case difficult. Although 22-year-old North Star employee Mike Hill had tried to help Aaron, he soon confessed
营地的急救医疗技术员乔吉特·科斯蒂根也因篡改证人罪被起诉。据另一组试图在亚伦最后时刻帮助他的辅导员迈克·希尔称，她曾试图说服一些学生修改他们给治安官办公室的书面陈述，使他们看起来不那么有罪。这些针对乔吉特·科斯蒂根的指控后来因证据不足而被撤销。检察官还有其他问题，这使得追究此案变得困难。尽管22岁的北极星员工迈克·希尔曾试图帮助亚伦，但他很快承认
that he'd committed a crime against another camper. In December 1993, he had sexually abused a 17-year-old boy in a previous program and made him perform sex acts in exchange for food. This crime completely undermined Hill's credibility as a witness. Hill subsequently pleaded guilty to one count of forcible sexual abuse. He had been the only North Star staff member willing to testify against the company, but the prosecutors knew they could no longer use him. However, two of Aaron's fellow campers were willing to testify and did so at a preliminary hearing. In closing arguments, a lawyer for the prosecution stated,
他曾对另一名营员犯罪。1993年12月，他曾在之前的项目中性虐待了一名17岁的男孩，并强迫他以性行为换取食物。这一罪行完全破坏了希尔作为证人的可信度。希尔随后承认犯有一项强迫性虐待罪。他曾是唯一愿意出庭指控该公司的北极星员工，但检察官知道他们不能再使用他了。然而，亚伦的两名营友愿意作证，并在预审听证会上作了证。在结案陈词中，检方律师陈述道：
Once it was decided that Aaron was a faker, a manipulator, that was the party line at North Star. They said, we ignore Aaron because he's faking. I don't know how you fake a 23 pound weight loss in 24 days." Following the hearing, all of the defendants were ordered to stand trial. Eventually, most of the defendants struck plea deals that saw their felony charges reduced. Five of them pleaded guilty to negligent homicide, which is a Class A misdemeanor in Utah. Those who accepted this plea included two of Aaron's counsellors, Sonny Duncan and Jeff Hohenstein, emergency medical technician Georgette Costigan, and North Star co-owners Lance Jagger and Bill Henry. Jagger and Henry also pleaded guilty to operating a program that violated licensing regulations.
“一旦决定亚伦是个骗子、一个操纵者，这就是北极星的口径。他们说，我们无视亚伦，因为他在装病。我不知道你怎么能装出24天内体重减轻23磅的效果。”听证会后，所有被告都被命令接受审判。最终，大多数被告达成了认罪协议，使他们的重罪指控被减轻。其中五人承认犯有过失杀人罪，这在犹他州属于A级轻罪。接受此认罪的人包括亚伦的两名辅导员桑尼·邓肯和杰夫·霍恩斯坦、急救医疗技术员乔吉特·科斯蒂根以及北极星联合创始人兰斯·贾格尔和比尔·亨利。贾格尔和亨利还承认经营了一个违反许可法规的项目。
These defendants were given a one-year suspended sentence, three years probation, and ordered to each pay a $2,500 fine. They were also ordered to perform community service. The sixth defendant pleaded guilty to a lesser charge of attempting to abuse a disabled child. Aaron Bacon fit the legal definition of being a disabled child as his physical illness that began shortly after he arrived at Northstar left him unable to care for himself. This defendant received probation and community service. And the seventh defendant was permitted to sign a diversion program agreement in exchange
这些被告被判处一年缓刑、三年缓刑，并被命令每人支付2,500美元的罚款。他们还被命令进行社区服务。第六名被告承认犯有虐待残疾儿童未遂的较轻罪名。亚伦·培根符合残疾儿童的法律定义，因为他在到达北极星后不久开始的身体疾病使他无法照顾自己。该被告被判处缓刑和社区服务。第七名被告被允许签署一份转处项目协议，以换取
for nine months of good behaviour. But the final defendant refused to cut a deal. Craig Fisher had been just 19 when he'd had to care for Aaron as one of his three rotating camp counsellors. He had demonstrated a rather belligerent attitude during the preliminary hearing, with Sally Bacon reporting that when the judge wasn't looking, Fisher had looked at her, sneered, and given her the finger. While his co-defendants had been convinced to accept plea agreements to avoid a long trial and harsher charges, Fisher rejected the idea outright. He went to trial facing the third degree felony charge of abuse or neglect of a disabled child.
九个月的良好表现。但最后一名被告拒绝达成协议。克雷格·费舍尔在担任亚伦的三名轮换营地辅导员之一时年仅19岁。他在预审听证会上表现出相当好斗的态度，萨莉·培根报告说，当法官没注意时，费舍尔看着她，冷笑并向她竖中指。虽然他的共同被告被说服接受认罪协议以避免漫长的审判和更严厉的指控，但费舍尔直接拒绝了这个想法。他面临虐待或忽视残疾儿童的三级重罪指控并接受审判。
Some of Aaron's fellow campers were called as witnesses, as were the other North Star employees who'd pleaded out. Aaron Bacon's parents also testified. Craig Fish's attorney argued that his client had merely been following the orders of his superiors and had no real say in how Aaron Bacon was to be treated. When his client had responded to Aaron's complaints by yelling at him, he'd just been trying to help him. It didn't take the jury long to find Craig Fisher guilty. After his conviction, Fisher went to hug Sally Bacon, telling her he'd had no idea how sick Aaron had really been. Sally replied that even if he hadn't known how unwell Aaron was, he hadn't done anything to help him. She told Fisher that she
亚伦的一些营友被传唤为证人，其他认罪的北极星员工也被传唤。亚伦·培根的父母也作了证。克雷格·费舍尔的律师辩称，他的当事人只是在执行上级的命令，对亚伦·培根如何被对待没有真正的发言权。当他的当事人通过对他大喊大叫来回应亚伦的抱怨时，他只是想帮助他。陪审团没花多久就裁定克雷格·费舍尔有罪。定罪后，费舍尔去拥抱萨莉·培根，告诉她他根本不知道亚伦病得有多重。萨莉回答说，即使他不知道亚伦病得有多重，他也没有做任何事来帮助他。她告诉费舍尔，她
hoped he would learn from the tragedy and would never again treat another human that badly. Then she hugged him back in a display of forgiveness. When it came time for Craig Fisher to be sentenced, his attorney pointed to this hug as a sign of his client's remorse. This left Sally feeling used, and when she stood to read her victim impact statement, she made sure to mention how Fisher had previously glared at her and given the finger. Fisher was ultimately sentenced to one year in a county jail. He appealed his conviction and lost. Fisher was later released after serving only a few months of his sentence. Sally and Bob Bacon filed a civil suit against Northstar, which was settled out of court and
希望他能从这场悲剧中吸取教训，永远不要再那样对待另一个人。然后她拥抱了他，作为一种宽恕的表现。当克雷格·费舍尔被判刑时，他的律师指出这个拥抱是他当事人悔改的标志。这让萨莉感到被利用了，当她站起来宣读受害者影响陈述时，她特意提到了费舍尔之前是如何怒视她并向她竖中指的。费舍尔最终被判处一年县监狱监禁。他上诉定罪但败诉。费舍尔在服刑仅几个月后就被释放了。萨莉和鲍勃·培根对北极星提起了民事诉讼，该诉讼在庭外和解，并且
paid by the defendant's insurance companies. The couple also became crusaders against the wilderness therapy industry, speaking out in the news and on television programs about how they were misled and what their son's experience had been. They also demanded stronger legislation and industry oversight. In an interview with the Salt Lake Tribune, Bob Bacon stated, The ignorance, arrogance, incompetence, callousness and greed of the people running these programs is proving repeatedly to be dangerous, abusive and even fatal. The lessons are not being learned. The Bacon's faced harsh pushback from wilderness therapy advocates, who victim blamed and smeared their family's name by claiming Aaron, Sally and Bob were all drug addicts. Parents of other children who'd been enrolled at wilderness therapy camps were among
由被告的保险公司支付。这对夫妇也成为了反对荒野治疗行业的斗士，他们在新闻和电视节目中公开讲述他们是如何被误导的，以及他们儿子的经历。他们还要求加强立法和行业监管。在接受《盐湖城论坛报》采访时，鲍勃·培根表示：“经营这些项目的人的无知、傲慢、无能、冷酷和贪婪，一次又一次地证明是危险、虐待甚至致命的。教训并没有被吸取。”培根夫妇面临着来自荒野治疗倡导者的严厉反击，这些人指责受害者，并声称亚伦、萨莉和鲍勃都是吸毒者，以此抹黑他们家庭的名声。其他曾将孩子送入荒野治疗营的父母也在其中
those critiquing the couple. Six months after Aaron's death, the state of Utah revoked Northstar's license and the camp was permanently shut down. Some parents were furious about this, with one mother asking Sally, Where did you think you were sending him? A daycare. Sally later told author Maya Salavitz about this interaction and added, They wanted a boot camp and that's what they were sold. I didn't want a boot camp, so that's what I was sold. And see, that's what they didn't understand. These people sell you whatever you're looking for.
批评这对夫妇的人之列。在亚伦去世六个月后，犹他州吊销了北极星（Northstar）的执照，该营地被永久关闭。一些家长对此感到愤怒，一位母亲问萨莉：“你以为你把他送到哪里去了？托儿所吗？”萨莉后来向作家玛雅·萨拉维茨讲述了这次互动，并补充道：“他们想要的是新兵训练营，而这正是他们被推销的东西。我并不想要新兵训练营，所以我被推销了那个。你看，这就是他们不明白的地方。这些人会向你兜售任何你想要的东西。”
they didn't understand. These people sell you whatever you're looking for. In her 2006 book, Help at Any Cost, How the Troubled Teen Industry Cons Parents and Hurts Kids, Maya Salavitz noted that at least nine other children had died in wilderness therapy programs in the years following Aaron's death. Most of these deaths occurred when teenagers were denied requests for water, food or medical attention. That number has increased in the years since Salavitz's book was published, with non-profit organization Breaking Code Silence counting more than 30 wilderness therapy deaths since 1990 and 175 in the troubled teen industry overall. One occurred as recently as February 2024, when a 12-year-old boy was found dead at a camp in North Carolina. Other abuses aren't fatal but have still resulted in trauma. Children have been forced to perform
他们不明白。这些人会向你兜售任何你想要的东西。在玛雅·萨拉维茨2006年的著作《不惜一切代价的帮助：问题青少年行业如何欺骗父母并伤害孩子》中，她指出，在亚伦去世后的几年里，至少还有九名儿童在荒野治疗项目中死亡。这些死亡大多发生在青少年被拒绝提供水、食物或医疗救助时。自萨拉维茨的书出版以来，这一数字有所增加，非营利组织“打破沉默准则”（Breaking Code Silence）统计，自1990年以来，荒野治疗导致了超过30人死亡，整个问题青少年行业共有175人死亡。最近的一起发生在2024年2月，一名12岁男孩被发现死在北卡罗来纳州的一个营地。其他虐待行为虽然不致命，但仍造成了创伤。孩子们被迫进行
manual labour, ordered to attack one another verbally in order to gain privileges, and sexually assaulted. Other abuses have included the denial of basic hygiene and sanitary items, and forcing teens to march with their ankles tied until their feet bled. In one instance, a girl was made to dress as a sex worker and given a name tag that read shameful slut. The boys in her group were told to call her slut, hoe and bitch. Some teenagers were forced to wear diapers, gagged with sanitary products, and ordered to clean toilets with their bare hands. There have been numerous cases of teenagers suiciding while in treatment programs, or coming to harm after trying to run away from one.
体力劳动，被命令互相进行言语攻击以换取特权，并遭到性侵犯。其他虐待行为还包括拒绝提供基本的卫生和清洁用品，并强迫青少年在脚踝被绑住的情况下行军，直到双脚流血。有一次，一名女孩被迫打扮成性工作者，并被贴上写着“可耻的荡妇”的名牌。她小组里的男孩被告知要叫她“荡妇”、“妓女”和“婊子”。一些青少年被迫穿尿布，用卫生用品堵住嘴，并被命令用赤手清洁厕所。有许多青少年在治疗项目中自杀，或在试图逃跑时受到伤害的案例。
Although different states have passed laws relating to the troubled teen industry over the years, a lack of regulation and oversight has meant that teenagers have continued to suffer at the hands of unqualified and abusive individuals. In 2020, the industry was in the national spotlight again when media personality Paris Hilton spoke out publicly about her experience at Provo Canyon School, an involuntary residential treatment centre for teens in Provo, Utah. In the late 1990s, when Hilton was 16, she had gone through a rebellious phase. Her parents eventually sent her to a wilderness therapy camp and later Provo Canyon School in the hopes it would correct her behaviour. Hilton stayed at Provo Canyon School for 11 months and
尽管多年来不同州通过了与问题青少年行业相关的法律，但由于缺乏监管和监督，青少年继续在不合格和虐待成性的人手中遭受痛苦。2020年，当媒体名人帕里斯·希尔顿公开讲述她在犹他州普罗沃的普罗沃峡谷学校（Provo Canyon School）——一家针对青少年的非自愿寄宿治疗中心——的经历时，该行业再次成为全国关注的焦点。20世纪90年代末，16岁的希尔顿经历了一段叛逆期。她的父母最终将她送往一个荒野治疗营，后来又送到了普罗沃峡谷学校，希望这能纠正她的行为。希尔顿在普罗沃峡谷学校待了11个月，
was released around the time she turned 18. She has testified before Congress about her experiences in these troubled teen programs, stating, "...these programs promised healing, growth and support, but instead did not allow me to speak, move freely or even look out a window for two years. I was force-fed medications and sexually abused by the staff. I was violently restrained and dragged down hallways, stripped naked, and thrown into solitary confinement. My parents were completely deceived, lied to, and manipulated by this for-profit industry about the inhumane treatment I was experiencing." Paris Hilton's revelations led to others coming forward to share their stories on social media
并在她18岁左右时获释。她曾在国会作证，讲述了她在这些问题青少年项目中的经历，她说：“……这些项目承诺治愈、成长和支持，但实际上却不允许我说话、自由走动，甚至在两年内连窗外都不能看。我被强行喂食药物，并受到工作人员的性虐待。我被暴力约束，在走廊里被拖行，被剥光衣服，并被关进禁闭室。我的父母完全被这个营利性行业欺骗、谎言和操纵，不知道我正在经历非人的待遇。”帕里斯·希尔顿的揭露促使其他人站出来在社交媒体上分享他们的故事，
as well as increased attention from journalists and the public. Hilton subsequently worked with Utah lawmakers on a new law aimed at improving industry regulation. It came into effect in March 2021. Under this law, troubled teen programs have to submit to more annual inspections and report use of physical restraints to the Utah Office of Licensing. As of 2024, there is still no federal oversight of the troubled teen industry, and there are more than 10,000 such programs operating in the United States. Utah has more of these facilities than anywhere else in the world.
同时也引起了记者和公众的更多关注。希尔顿随后与犹他州立法者合作制定了一项旨在改善行业监管的新法律。该法律于2021年3月生效。根据该法律，问题青少年项目必须接受更多的年度检查，并向犹他州许可办公室报告身体约束的使用情况。截至2024年，问题青少年行业仍然没有联邦监管，美国有超过10,000个此类项目在运营。犹他州拥有的此类设施比世界上任何其他地方都多。
This is due in part to the state's strict parental laws, which supports parents making decisions for their children over a minor's personal wishes. While many states have now made it illegal to hold teenagers in such programs against their will, this is not the case in Utah. It's estimated that the industry still brings the state almost half a billion dollars in revenue each year. The individuals who were charged for the death of Aram Bacon moved on with their lives. North Star co-owner Bill Henry violated the terms of his probation by only completing 86 hours of community service instead of the court ordered 1,440 hours.
这在一定程度上归因于该州严格的父母法律，该法律支持父母在未成年人的个人意愿之上为孩子做出决定。虽然许多州现在已将违背青少年意愿将其关押在此类项目中定为非法，但在犹他州并非如此。据估计，该行业每年仍为该州带来近五亿美元的收入。因亚伦·培根之死而被起诉的人继续着他们的生活。北极星的共同所有者比尔·亨利违反了缓刑条款，仅完成了86小时的社区服务，而不是法院判决的1,440小时。
He then violated it again by moving interstate to Oregon where his wife had been hired by another wilderness therapy program. The couple's son, Eric Henry, was later hired by the same company while still on probation for his role in Aaron Bacon's death. In 2023, streaming platform Netflix released a documentary about wilderness therapy titled Hell Camp, which focused primarily on the programs led by Steve Cardasano. Lance Jagger appeared in the documentary to talk about his time as an employee at Cardasano's program Challenger. Now well into his middle age and wearing a breathing tube, Jagger stated,
随后，他因搬迁到俄勒冈州而再次违反缓刑规定，他的妻子在那里被另一家荒野治疗项目聘用。这对夫妇的儿子埃里克·亨利后来也被同一家公司聘用，当时他仍因在亚伦·培根死亡案中的角色而处于缓刑期。2023年，流媒体平台Netflix发布了一部关于荒野治疗的纪录片《地狱营》（Hell Camp），主要关注由史蒂夫·卡达萨诺领导的项目。兰斯·贾格尔在纪录片中露面，谈论了他作为卡达萨诺项目“挑战者”（Challenger）员工的时光。现在已步入中年的贾格尔戴着呼吸管，他说道：
We didn't break them down to punish them. We broke them down to get rid of the old crap and help them be a better and more positive person. Some of the kids were so scared they'd almost pass out. And that was fine by me. I wanted them to have a little fear." Aaron Bacon's parents still feel that the adults involved in their son's death paid too small a price for their role in his demise. They have spoken out against Lance Jagger's assertion that he's providing tough love, with Sally Bacon telling ABC News, "...you can do tough love as a parent because you love the child. They can do tough. They can't do love." Police gave Sally and Bob their son's journal after they had copied its contents as evidence.
“我们摧毁他们不是为了惩罚他们。我们摧毁他们是为了摆脱旧的垃圾，帮助他们成为一个更好、更积极的人。有些孩子害怕得几乎要昏过去。这对我来说没问题。我希望他们有一点恐惧。”亚伦·培根的父母仍然认为，参与他们儿子死亡的成年人为他们在儿子死亡中所扮演的角色付出的代价太小了。他们公开反对兰斯·贾格尔声称他提供的是“严厉的爱”的说法，萨莉·培根告诉美国广播公司新闻：“……作为父母，你可以进行严厉的爱，因为你爱孩子。他们可以做到严厉。但他们做不到爱。”警方在将亚伦的日记作为证据复印后，将其交给了萨莉和鲍勃。
The entries were painful for the couple to read as they detailed Aaron's physical decline in excruciating detail as well as his emotional pain. Some pages were dotted with Aaron's blood. But there were also lines that spoke of Arren's love for his family. In one early entry, he reflected on his goodbye before being taken into Northstar and wrote, I should have told them that I loved them and I'm sorry I didn't. I didn't even hug them and that was terrible. I sure wish I could hug them and tell them I love them now." Music There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这对夫妇读到这些日记时感到非常痛苦，因为日记详细记录了亚伦身体状况的恶化以及他的情感痛苦。有些页面上点缀着亚伦的血迹。但也有一些文字表达了亚伦对家人的爱。在早期的一篇日记中，他反思了在被带到北极星之前的告别，写道：“我应该告诉他们我爱他们，我很抱歉我没有。我甚至没有拥抱他们，那太糟糕了。我真希望现在能拥抱他们并告诉他们我爱他们。”音乐 本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。